turning from 1970s SQL originally SQL
emerged as a language to tame data with
an IBM system R it evolved through
various versions captivating developers
worldwide today SQL Reigns as the de
facto language for relational databases
with a future full of Endless
Possibilities diving deep into the world
of databases SQL or structural query
language is a standardized language for
managing relational databases it
supports complex queries and various
types of joints common SQL databases
include MySQL post GRE SQL and Oracle
SQL is widely used in web development if
you are looking to become a web
developer then learning SQL can be your
MasterCard and to get ahead with this
successful career simplylearn offers
postgraduate program in full stack web
development government with this amazing
program you will be benefited with
Caltech ctme postgraduate certificate
receive up to 25 CEUs and caltex ctme
attend master classes from Caltech ctma
instructors live virtual classes led by
industry experts Hands-On projects and
integrated Labs by the end of this
course you will be skilled with agile
Java hibernate and jpa spring core 50
HTML5 and css3 AWS JavaScript and there
is used list on the board expertise and
tools like angular css3 Docker git HTML5
Jenkins mongodb and MySQL will add value
to your resume so hurry up and enroll
Now find the complete course details
from the link in the description box
millions of Learners are benefited with
our courses listen to their success
stories and their own words learning is
growing and we not only decided to grow
together in life but learn and succeed
together as well I successfully switched
my career to postal Java domain with a
15 salary hike and I was able to grab
new opportunities in my current
organization and also receive a 10
salary hike hey I am swamijit Basu I am
a senior QA engineer at Encore Inc and I
am show me and I work as a senior
quality Analyst at doodle blue
Innovation we started our upscaling
journey together which simply learned
and certainly we made the right choice
after our marriage I had to relocate to
Bangalore and take a year Gap after
working 45 years but I decided to
restart my career again and make a
switch to software domain so I enrolled
myself in full stack Java developer
program from Simply learn seeing my
wife's passion for learning every day
inspired me to take up a course on
simply learn as well I've always been
passionate about technology and learning
devops was always in my bucket list when
I saw simply learns collaboration with
Caltech ctme I decided to take a course
on PG devops after the course I not only
switched my career to post a Java
development with a 15 increment in the
salary but now also I can work from home
since it's a software domain and being
the new mom that's the best thing one
could ask for to spend time with little
one during these early years
for me learning devops was fun and
fulfilling at the same time earlier I
had to rely on others at work but after
upskilling myself I single-handedly can
set up the entire blueprint on my code
base alone and get the desired output
and because of that I could grab new
projects in my organization with a 10
percent salary high we enrolled to
upscale ourselves when we were expecting
our first child so upscaling Journey
with simply learn would be undoubtedly
very special to both of us while doing
the course we did come across a lot of
challenges due to the pregnancy but my
wife showed me was a great inspiration
for me as she was handling it all
together and she kept motivating and
inspiring me all the way moreover the
recorded classes and the weekend class
helped us maintain the balance between
work and learning apart from work we
love to spend time with our little one
learning by simply Learned was quite a
fulfilling experience for both of us we
believe that good doesn't happen
overnight rather it's a journey of
several all steps and upskilling is one
of them and to get ahead with this
successful career simply an offers post
graduate program in full stack web
development with this amazing program
you will be benefited with Caltech ctme
postgraduate certificate receive up to
25 CEUs and caltex ctme attend master
classes from Caltech ctma instructors
live virtual classes led by industry
experts Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs by the end of this course you will
be skilled with agile Java hibernet and
jpa spring core 50 HTML5 and css3 AWS
JavaScript and there is used list on the
board expertise and tools like angular
css3 Docker git HTML5 Jenkins mongodb
and MySQL will add value to your resume
so hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box
so according to Oracle a database is an
organized collection of structured
information or data that is typically
stored electronically in a computer
system
a database is usually controlled by a
database management system or dbms
so it is a storage system that has a
collection of data relational databases
stored data in the form of tables that
can be easily retrieved managed and
updated
you can organize data into tables rows
columns and index it to make it easier
to find relevant information now talking
about some of the popular databases
we have mySQL database we also have
Oracle database then we have mongodb
which is a nosql database
next we have Microsoft SQL Server next
we have Apache Cassandra which is a free
and open source nosql database and
finally we have postgres SQL now let's
learn
what is SQL so SQL is a domain specific
language to communicate with databases
SQL was initially developed by IBM
most databases use structured query
language or SQL for writing and querying
data SQL commands help you to store
process analyze and manipulate databases
with this let's look at what a table is
so this is how a table in a database
looks like
so here you can see the name of the
table is players
on the top you can see the column names
so we have the player ID the player name
the country to which the player belongs
to and we also have the goals scored by
each of the players so these are also
known as fields in a database
here each row represents a record or a
tuple
so if you have the player ID which is
one zero three here the name of the
player is Daniel he is from England and
the number of goals here score is seven
so you can use SQL commands to query
update insert records and do a lot of
other tasks
now we'll see what the features of SQL
are SQL lets you access any information
stored in a relational database with SQL
queries data is extracted from the
database in a very efficient way
the structured query language is
compatible with all database systems
from Oracle IBM to Microsoft and it
doesn't require much coding to manage
databases
now we will see applications of SQL SQL
is used to create a database Define its
structure implement it and let you
perform many functions SQL is also
useful maintaining an already existing
database SQL is a powerful language for
entering data modifying data and
extracting data in a database SQL is
extensively used as a client server
language to connect the front end with
the back end the supporting the client
server architecture
SQL when deployed as data control
language DCL helps protect your database
from unauthorized access in this session
we will learn about ER diagram starting
with what is an ER diagram and why it's
been so much used by the companies then
we will learn about the symbols used in
the ear diagram and get familiar with
the components of it so hey everyone I
am abisara Ahuja from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on ER diagram in
dbms but before we begin if you love
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update let's start
have you ever wondered how these big
e-commerce companies manage their tons
of data that keeps updating every second
and these data sets keep on updating in
the databases to perform operations on
this data they should have a conceptual
understanding of these databases and
this is done by understanding ear
diagrams of the databases SQL Developer
by simply learn
in this session we will learn who is the
SQL Developer and what are the
responsibilities in a company then we
will focus on the skills required to
become a successful SQL Developer we'll
see the expected average salary in both
U.S and India we will also discuss how
to become a SQL Developer and look at
the top companies hiring for SQL
developers so hey everyone I am abhisar
Ahuja from Simply learn and welcome to
this video on how to become a SQL
Developer but before we begin if you
love watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to now
miss an update
when going through some of the popular
job boards online you would easily see
SQL Developer is one of the most
demanding jobs seeked by companies as we
all know today companies collect vast
volumes of data and store it in their
own databases they want professionals
with a good understanding of data who
can keep it safe and secure so first we
will understand who is a SQL Developer
SQL Developer is a person who is
accountable in creating and managing
huge data assets of a company
in other terms SQL Developer is a person
who can develop SQL databases as well as
write-in test code let's understand this
with the help of an example let's say we
want to search a particular product on
Amazon website and Amazon has stored all
its data about products in a database
now we will write the product name in
the search bar and when we click on the
search button it will run a SQL query
that fetches all the information about
the product and displays us on the
website so this is the basic task done
by a SQL Developer
now we will understand the
responsibilities of a SQL Developer all
databases have a structure and logic
behind how data is stored and retrieved
a SQL Developer designs the database
accordingly for businesses that is
called database modeling after the
database is created and deployed it's
the SQL Developer who is responsible for
fixing the general issues of the
database
SQL Developer should be well versed with
structured query language to create
optimized SQL queries and refines the
existing ones to extract information
from the database
SQL developers run several diagnostic
tests to keep a check on the server and
the database in order to understand how
to organize company's data SQL
developers must communicate with
tactical and non-technical persons from
the business and SQL Developer also
gathers client requirements and
identifies the features that the
database owners want
as data is an asset to a company SQL
developers backup and restore data for
the clients they also perform tasks like
data management and data migration that
is if a company has stored all its data
on a local storage and now it pawn its
data to be stored in a cloud storage so
the safe transmission of the data from
local storage to cloud storage is known
as data migration and that is done by
the SQL developers after knowing the
responsibilities now we should look for
skill set required to be a good SQL
Developer
one should have a good knowledge of SQL
commands functions joints and procedures
let's have a look at few commands such
as create drop alter and truncate these
commands come under data definition
language we also have insert update and
delete commands these commands come
under data manipulation language we have
Grant and Devo commands these commands
come under data control language we also
have Commit rollback and save point
commands these come under transaction
control language these are the basic
commands a SQL Developer should be
familiar with and a SQL Developer may
have a little command on any one
programming language you don't have to
be expert in programming all you need is
how to interface between application and
your database for example you are using
MySQL and your web application is based
on PHP then you should know how to
connect your application to the database
and how to issue queries
how to fetch results and then how to
display it to the users
one should have a good understanding of
various database Management systems such
as MySQL Microsoft Access Oracle post
way SQL dbase Fox Pro SQL Lite IBM db2
LibreOffice base mariadb and Microsoft
SQL Server
one should know integration of databases
with data visualization software such as
power bi and Tableau which helps
businesses to make better decisions and
give you an add-on as a SQL Developer
one should develop critical thinking and
problem solving skills to create
optimized queries
now we'll see how a SQL Developer is
compensated in both United States and
India
in the United States SQL developers grow
an average salary of dollar 72 282 per
annum in India the average salary of a
SQL Developer is rupees 4 lakh 49532.
now we'll see how person can become a
good SQL Developer for that one should
have a good command on structured query
language and know how to interact with
database management system and can issue
queries to get the desired result
earning industry recognized SQL
Developer certifications such as
Microsoft certified professional
developer mcpd or Oracle PL SQL
Developer certified associate which
usually require a passing score on an
exam
and it's important to accumulate as much
practical experience as possible start
by designing creating and querying small
databases connected with your hobbies
and interests for example your favorite
music videos or your personal finances
this will enable you to gain experience
test your knowledge and build your
project portfolio which will be highly
beneficial when you start applying for
your first full-time position
now we will see some major companies
recruiting SQL developers first we have
the multinational Financial Services
Corporation American Express followed by
the multinational Professional Services
Network ernstein we also have the
messaging company WhatsApp then we have
the e-commerce giant Amazon as well as
the technology and Computer Solutions
company Dell finally in a list of
companies we have the multinational
technology company Google so let's
understand what 10-year diagram is
an entity relationship diagram
describes the relationship of entities
that needs to be stored in a database
ear diagram is mainly a structural
design for the database it is a
framework made using specialized symbols
to define the relationship between
entities ER diagrams are created based
on the three main components entities
attributes relationships let's
understand the use of ER diagram with
the help of a real world example here a
school needs all its Student Records to
be stored digitally so they approach an
I.T company to do so a person from the
company will meet the school authorities
not all their requirements describe them
in the form of ER diagram and get it
close checked by the school authorities
as the school authorities approve the
rear diagram the database Engineers
would carry further implementation
let's have a view of an ear diagram
the following diagram showcases two
entities student and course and the
relationship the relationship described
between student and course is many to
many as a course can be opted by several
students and a student can opt for more
than one course here student is the
entity and it possesses the attributes
that is student ID student name and
student age
and the course entity has attributes
such as course ID and course name
now we have an understanding of ER
diagram let us see why it has been so
popular
The Logical structure of the database
provided by ear diagram communicates the
landscape of business to different teams
in the company which is eventually
needed to support the business
ear diagram is a GUI representation of
The Logical structure of a database
which gives a better understanding of
the information to be stored in a
database
database designers can use ER diagrams
as a blueprint which reduces complexity
and helps them save time to build
databases quickly
ear diagrams helps to identify the
entities that exist in a system and the
relationships between those entities
after knowing its uses now we should get
familiar with the symbols used in ear
diagram
the rectangle symbol represents the
entities oval symbol represents
attributes a rectangle embedded in a
rectangle represents a weak entity a
dashed oval represents a derived
attribute a diamond symbol represents a
relationship among entities double all
symbol represents multi-valued
attributes now we should dive in and
learn about the components of ER diagram
there are three main components of Air
diagram entity attribute and
relationship
entities have weak entity attributes are
further classified into key attribute
composite attribute multi-valued
attribute and derived attribute
relationships are also classified into
one-to-one relationships one to many
relationships many to one relationships
and many to many relationships
let's understand these components of
fear diagram
starting with entities
an entity can be either a living or a
non-living component an entity is
showcased as a rectangle in an ear
diagram let's understand this with the
help of an ear diagram here both student
and course are in rectangular shape and
are called entities and they represent
the relationship study in a diamond
shape let's transition to weak entity
an entity that makes Airlines over
another entity is called a weak entity
the weak entity is showcased as a double
rectangle in ER diagonal in the example
below the school is a strong entity
because it has a primary key attribute
School number unlike the school the
classroom is a weak entity because it
does not have any primary key and the
room number attribute here acts only as
a discriminator and node of primary key
now let us know about attributes
attribute an attribute exhibits the
properties of an entity an attribute is
Illustrated with an oval shape in any
Air diagram in the example below student
is an entity and the properties of
student such as address age name and
role number are called its attributes
let's see our first classification under
attribute that is key attribute the key
attribute uniquely identifies an entity
from an entity set
the text of a key attribute is
underlined in the example below we have
a student entity and it has attributes
name address row number and age but here
row number can uniquely identify a
student from a set of students that's
why it is termed as a key attribute now
we will see composite attribute
an attribute that is composed of several
other attributes is known as a composite
attribute an oval showcases the
composite attribute and the composite
attribute over is further connected with
other roles in the example below we can
see an attribute name
which can have further supports such as
first name middle name and last name
these attributes with further
classification is known as composite
attribute now let's have a look at
multi-valued attribute an attribute that
can process more than one value are
called multi-valued attributes these are
represented as double old shape
in the example below the student entity
has attributes phone number roll number
name and age out of these attributes
phone number can have more than one
entry and the attribute with more than
one value is called multi-valued
attribute
let's see derived attribute an attribute
that can be derived from other
attributes of the entity is known as a
derived attribute in the ER diagram the
derived attribute is represented by
dashed over and in the example below
student entity has both date of birth
and age as attributes here age is a
derived attribute as it can be derived
by subtracting current date from the
student date of birth
now after knowing attributes let's
understand relationship in ER diagram a
relationship is showcased by the diamond
shape in the ear diagram it depicts the
relationship between two entities in the
below example student study course here
both student and course are entities and
studies the relationship between them
now let's go through the type of
relationship
first is one-to-one relationship when a
single element of an entity is
associated with the single element of
another entity this is called one-to-one
relationship
in the example below we have student and
identification card as entities we can
see a student has only one
identification card and an
identification card is given to one
student it represents a one-to-one
relationship
let's see the second one when too many
relationship when a single element of an
entity is associated with more than one
element of another entity is called when
too many relationship in the below
example a customer can place many orders
but a particular order cannot be placed
by many customers now we will have a
look at many to one relationship when
more than one element of an entity is
related to a single element of another
entity it is called many-to-one
relationship for example students have
to opt for a single course but a course
can be opted by number of students
let's see many to many relationship when
more than one element of an entity is
associated with more than one element of
another entity is called many to many
relationship
for example an employee can be assigned
to many projects and many employees can
be assigned to a particular project
now after having an understanding of PR
diagram let us know the points to keep
in mind while creating the ER diagram
first identify all the entities in the
system embed all the entities in a
rectangular shape and label them
appropriately this could be a customer a
manager an order an invoice a schedule
Etc
identify relationships between entities
and connect them using a diamond in the
middle illustrating the relationship do
not connect relationships
connect attributes with entities and
label them appropriately and the
attribute should be in our chip assure
that each entity only appears a single
time and eradicate any redundant
entities or relationships in the ear
diagram
make sure your ER diagram supports all
the data provided to design the database
make effective use of colors to
highlight key areas in new diagrams
there are mainly four types of SQL
commands so first we have data
definition language or ddl
so ddl commands change the structure of
the table like creating a table deleting
a table or altering a table all the
commands of ddl are Auto committed which
means it permanently save all the
changes in the database
we have create alter drop and turn
create as ddl commands
next we have data manipulation language
or DML for so DML commands are used to
modify your database it is responsible
for all forms of changes in the database
DML commands are not Auto committed
which means it can't permanently save
all the changes in the database
we have select update delete and insert
as DML commands now select command is
also referred to as dql or data query
language third we have data control
language or DCL
so DCL commands allow you to control
access to data within the database
these DCL commands are normally used to
create objects related to user access
and also control the distribution of
privileges among users
so we have Grant and revoke which are
the examples of data control language
finally we have something called as
transaction control language or TCL
so TCL commands allow the user to manage
database transactions commit and roll
back are example of TCL
now let's see the basic SQL command
structure
so first we have the select statement so
here you specify the various column
names that you want to fetch from the
table we write the table name using the
from statement
next we have the WHERE Clause to filter
out a table based on some conditions so
you can see here where condition 1
condition 2 and so on
then we have the group by Clause that
takes various column names so you can
write Group by column one column two and
so on
next we have the having Clause to filter
out tables based on groups
finally we have the order by Clause to
filter out the result in ascending or
descending order now talking about the
various data types in SQL
so we have exact numeric which has
integer small end bit and decimal then
we have approximate numeric which are
float and real
then we have some date and time data
type such as date time timestamp and
others
then we have string data type which
includes car this war car and text
finally we have binary data types
and binary data types have binary VAR
binary and image now let's see some of
the various operators that are present
in SQL
so first we have our basic arithmetic
operators so you have addition the
subtraction multiplication division and
modulus
then we have some logical operators like
all and any or between exists and so on
finally we have some comparison
operators such as equal to not equal to
this greater than less than greater than
equal to or less than equal to not less
than or not greater than now let me take
you to my MySQL workbench where we will
learn to write some of the import and
SQL commands use different statements
functions data types and operators that
we just learned in this session we will
learn how to install MySQL workbench and
then we will run some commands
firstly we will visit the official
Oracle website that is mysql.com
and now we'll move to the downloads page
now scroll down and click on my sequel
GPL downloads
now under Community downloads click on
MySQL installer for Windows
the current versions are available to
download
I will choose this installer and click
the download button
now here just click on no thanks just
start my download
when style installer has downloaded open
it
you may be prompted for permission click
yes
this opens the installer
you will be asked to choose the setup
type we will go with custom
pick next
now you have to select the products you
want to install
we will install only the MySQL server
MySQL shell and the MySQL World page
expand MySQL servers by double clicking
on it
and choose the version you want to
install and click on this Arrow
now you have to do the same thing for
applications expand applications
and choose the MySQL workbench version
you want to install and click on the
Arrow
you will do the same thing for MySQL
shell
and choose the latest version click on
the Arrow
so these are the products that have to
be installed in a system
now we'll click next
I'll click execute to download and
install the server
this may take a while depending on your
internet speed
as the download is completed click next
now you see the product configuration
click next
now we'll configure our SQL Server
instance
here we'll go with the default settings
and click next
and under authentication select use
strong password encryption for
authentication which is recommended and
click on next
now here set the password for your root
user by the way root is the default user
this user will have access to everything
I will set my password
now I'll click on next
and here also we'll keep the default
settings
and click on next
now to apply configuration we will
execute the process
once all the configuration steps are
complete click finish
now you will see the installation is
complete it will launch MySQL workbench
and MySQL shell after clicking on finish
so now the shell and workbench has
started
now we'll connect by clicking on the
root user it will ask for a password
enter the password and it will connect
successfully
thank you
yeah double page has started now we'll
just connect the server so first we'll
open command prompt
now we'll reach the path where MySQL
files are present
I'm going to do this PC
located C
program files
MySQL
my SQL Server 8.0 and then
I'll copy this path
now I'll open the command prompt and
write a command CD space
and paste the link and press enter
now we'll write another command that
will be MySQL
minus U
space
through minus p and press enter now it
will ask for your password just enter
the password
and press enter
now the server has started and now we'll
see some commands in MySQL workbench
first we will open MySQL workbench
now we'll click on the local instance
MySQL 80
and enter the password to connect to the
localhost
[Music]
the MySQL workbench has started now you
see some commands
the First Command you will see is show
databases
show databases semicolon and now we'll
select the whole command and click on
this execute button
and here we will see the result in the
result grid
these are the databases data stored
already in the database
no there are four databases that is
information schema MySQL performance
schema and S5s now we will select one of
the database we'll use MySQL
now we have selected the mySQL database
and now in this database we will see
which tables are stored in this mySQL
database to see that we will run a
command
show tables
these are the tables that are stored in
this mySQL database that is columns
underscore Drive component DB and much
more
now let me now go ahead and open my
MySQL workbench so in the search bar
I'll search for
MySQL workbench you can see I'm using
the 8.0 version
I'll click on it and
here it says welcome to mySQL workbench
and Below under connections you can see
I have already created a connection
which says local instance then you have
the root the local host and the port
number let me click on it
you can see the service the username is
root and I'll enter my password
and hit ok now this will open the SQL
editor so this is how the MySQL
workbench looks like here we learn some
of the basic SQL commands so first let
me show you the databases that are
already present
so the command is so databases
you can hit tab to autocomplete I'll use
a semicolon
I'll select this and here you on the top
you can see the execute button so if I
run this
below you can see the output which says
show databases seven rows returned which
means
currently there are seven databases
you can see the names
all right now
let's say I want to see the tables that
are present inside this database called
world
so I'll use the command use
World which is the database name
now let me run it so currently I am
using the world database so to display
the tables that are present in the world
database I can use the show command and
write show tables
give a semicolon and I'll hit Ctrl enter
this time to run it all right so you can
see the tables that are present inside
this
World database so we have three tables
in total City Country and Country
language
now if you are to see the rows that are
present in one of the tables you can use
the select command so I'll write select
star which basically means I want to
display all the columns so star here
means to display all the columns
then I'll write my
from
the table name that is City
so this command is going to display me
all the rows that are present inside the
city table
so if I hit Ctrl enter
all right you can see the message here
it says
1000 rows were written which means there
were total thousand records present
inside the city table
so here you can see there's an ID column
a name column this country code district
and population
all right
similarly you can check the structure of
the table by using the describe command
so I'll write describe
and then
I'll give the
table name that is City now let's just
run it
there you go the field shows the column
name so we have ID name country code
district population
type here shows the data type of each of
the columns so district is character 20
ID is an integer population is also
integer
null says yes or no which means if no
then there are no null values if it's
yes which means there are null values in
your table
key here represents whether you have any
primary key or foreign key
and these are some extra information now
let's learn how to create a table in
MySQL so I'll use the create table
command for this and before that
let me create a database
and I'll name it as SQL intro so the
command is create
database
and I'll give my database name that is
SQL underscore intro
let me keep a semicolon and hit Ctrl
enter
so you can see I have created a new
database now
if I run this command that is show
databases
you can see this
newly created database that is SQL intro
if I scroll down
there you go you can see the name here
SQL intro
okay now within this database we'll
create a table called employee details
now this will have the details of some
employees
so let me first show you how to create a
table
that will be present inside the SQL
intro database
so use the command create
table
and then
I'll give my table name that is going to
be employee underscore details
next
the syntax is
to give the column names so my first
column would be the name column which is
basically the employee name
followed by
the data type for this column since name
is a text column so I'll use War car
and I'll give a value of 25. so it can
hold only 25 characters
okay next I also want the age of the
employee now age is always an integer so
I'll give int
okay
then
we can have the gender of the employee
so gender can be represented as F or m f
for female and M for meal so I'm using
the car data type or character data type
and I'll give the value as 1.
then let's have the
date of join or doj and this is going to
be of data type date
all right
next we'll have the city name that is
the city to which the employee belongs
to
so again this is going to be war card
15.
finally we'll have a salary column
and salary will keep it as float since
salary can be in
decimal numbers as well now I'll give a
semicolon all right so let me just
quickly run through it so first
I wrote my create command then the table
which is also a keyword
followed by
the table name which is employee details
here and then we keep the column names
such as name each this gender
need to join City and salary
for each of the columns we also give the
data type
all right so let me just run it
okay so here you can see we have
successfully created our first table
now you can use the describe command to
see the structure of the table
I'll describe EMP underscore details
if I run this
there you go
so under field you can see the column
names then you have the data types
null represents if the table can accept
null values or not and these are
basically empty
and we haven't set any default
constraint
all right
moving ahead
now let's learn to add data to our table
using the insert command so on a notepad
I have already
written my insert statement let me just
copy it and then I'll explain it one by
one all right
so if you see this
so we have used an insert into statement
or a command followed by
the table name that is EMP details then
this is the syntax using values I have
passed in all the records so first we
have Jimmy which is the name of the
employee then we have 35 it basically
represents the age then m means the
gender of the sex
then we have the date of join
next we have the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the salary of the employee so this
particular information represents one
record or a tuple
similarly the next employee we have is
Shane you can see the age and other
information then we have Mary this
Dwayne Sarah and Ami
all right so let me go ahead and run
this
so this will help you insert
the values in the table that you have
created
you can see we have successfully
inserted six records
now
to display the records let me
use the select statement so I'm using
select star from EMP underscore details
if I run this
you can see my table here and the values
it has so we have the name column the
each column the state of join City
salary
and these are the values that you can
see here moving ahead now let's say you
want to see the Unique city names
present in the table
so in this case you can use the distinct
keyword along with the column name in
the select statement so let me show you
how you can print the distinct
city names that are present in our table
now if you notice this table clearly
we have Chicago Shear tell Boston Austin
this New York and this Seattle repeated
again so I only want to print the unique
values
so for that I can write my select
statement as select
distinct
then I'll give my column name which is
City from
my table name that is EMP details
if I run this
you can see
my query has returned five rows and
these are the values so we have Chicago
Seattle which was repeated twice is just
been shown once then we have Boston
Austin and New York now let's see how
you can use inbuilt
aggregate functions in SQL
so suppose we want to count the number
of employees in the table so in that
case you can use the count function in
the select statement so let me show you
how to do that
so I'll write
select
I'll use my function name that is count
now since I want to know the
total number of employees I am going to
use their name
inside the brackets from
employee underscore details
now if I run this
this will return the total number of
employees that are present in the table
so we have six employees in total
now if you see here in the result it
says count name now this column is
actually not readable at all so what SQL
provides is something called as an alias
name so you can give an alias to the
resultant output so here I can write
select count of name
and use an alias as as
I can give an alias as
count underscore name
and run this statement again
there you go you can see here in the
resultant
output we have the column name as count
name which was our Alias name now
suppose we want to get the total sum of
salaries you can use another aggregate
function called sum
so I'll write my
select statement and this time instead
of count I am going to write sum and
since I want to find the sum of salaries
so inside the bracket I'll give my
salary column from
my table name that is employee details
if I run this
this will result in the total sum of
salaries so basically it adds up all the
salaries that were present in the salary
column now let's say you want to find
the average salary so instead of sum you
can write the average function which is
AVG so this will give you the average
salary
from the column salary so you can see it
here this is average salary now if you
want you can give an alias name to this
as well now you can select specific
columns from the table by using the
column names in the select statement
so initially we were selecting all the
columns for example like you saw here
the star represents that we want to see
all the columns from the employee
details table
now suppose you want to
see only specific columns you can
mention those column names in the select
statement
so let's say I want to select
just the name age
and the city column
from my table that is employee details
so this will result
in displaying only the name agent City
column from the table if I run it there
you go it has given only three columns
to me now SQL has a where Clause to
filter rows based on a particular
condition
so if you want to filter your table
based on specific conditions you can use
where Clause now where Clause comes
after you give your table name
so suppose you want to find the
employees with age greater than 30 in
this case you can use a where Clause so
let me show you how to do it
I'll write select
star from
my table name that is
employee details
and after this I'll use my where Clause
so I'll write where
each
greater than
30.
if I run this
it will give me the output where the age
is only greater than 30 so it excluded
everything that is less than 30. so we
have four employees whose age is greater
than 30 here
now suppose you want to find only female
employees from the table you can also
use a where Clause here
so I'll write select
let's say I want only the name the
gender which is sex here
comma City
from my table that is employee details
where
I'll give my column name that is 6 is
equal to
since I want only the female employees
I'll give
f
and run this statement
okay you can see here our employee table
has three female employees so suppose
you want to find the details of the
employees who belong to Chicago or
Austin in this case you can use the or
operator
now the or operator in SQL displays a
record if any of the condition separated
by or is true
so let me show you what I mean
so since I want the employees who are
from Chicago and Austin
I can use an or operator so I'll write
select star from
EMP details which is my table name
then I'll give my where Clause where
City
equal to
I'll give my
city name as Chicago
and then I am going to use the or
operator or
City equal to
I'll write Austin
I'll give a semicolon and let me run it
there you go
so in the output you can see all the
employees
who belong to the city Chicago and
Austin
now there is another way to write the
same SQL query
so you can use an in operator to specify
multiple conditions
so let me just copy this
and instead of using the or operator
this time I am going to use the in
operator
so I'll delete this
after the where Clause I'm going to
write where City
and use the in operator
inside bracket
I'll give my city names as Chicago
and I want Austin so I'll give a comma
and write my next city name that is
Austin
so this query is exactly the same that
we wrote on top
let me run this
you will get the same output there you
go
so we have Jimmy and Dwayne who are from
Chicago and Austin respectively
now SQL provides the between operator
that selects values within a given range
the values can be numbers text or dates
so suppose you want to find the
employees whose date of join was between
1st of Jan 2000 and 31st of December
2010.
so let me show you how to do it
I'll write select star from
EMP details where
my date of join that is doj
between
I'll give my two date values that is
first off
Jan 2000
and
I'll give my
second value
the date value that is
31st of December 2010.
so every employee who has joined between
these two dates will be displayed in the
output
if I run it
we have two employees who had joined
between 2000 and 2010 so we have Jimmy
and Mary here who had joined in 2005 in
2009 respectively
all right
now in where Clause you can use the and
operator to specify multiple conditions
now the and operator displays a record
if all the conditions separated by and
are true
so let me show you an example I'll write
select
star from
employee details table
where
I want the age to be greater than 30.
and I want
6 to be male
all right so here you can see I have
specified two conditions so both the
conditions are true only then it will
result in an output
if I run it you can see there are two
employees who are male
and their age is greater than 30. now
let's talk about the group by statement
in SQL
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows like for example you want to find
the average salary of customers in each
department
now the group by statement is often used
with aggregate functions such as count
sum and average to group the results set
into one or more columns
let's say we want to find the total
salary of employees based on the gender
so in this case you can use the group by
clause
so I'll write select
let's say sex comma
I want to find the total sum of salary
as I'll give an alias name let's say
total salary
from
my table name that is employee details
next I am going to group it by sex
okay
let me run it there you go so we have
two genders male and female and here you
can see the total salary so what this
SQL statement did was first it grouped
all the employees based on the gender
and then it found the total salary
now SQL provides the order by keyword to
sort the result set in ascending or
descending order
now the order by keyword sorts the
records in ascending order by default to
sort the records in descending order you
can use the desc keyword
so let's say I want to sort my employee
details table
in terms of salary so I'll write select
star from
EMP underscore details
and I'll use my order by clause on the
salary column
so this will sort
all the records
in ascending order of their salary which
is by default you can see
the salary column is sorted in ascending
order
now suppose you want to sort the salary
column
and display it in descending order you
can use this keyword that is desc
let me run it
you can see the output now this time the
salary is sorted in descending order and
you have the other values as well now
let me show you some basic operations
that you can do using the select
statement
so suppose I write select
and do an addition operation let's say
plus 20
and I'll give an alias name as addition
if I run this
it will give me the sum of
10 and 20 that is 30.
similarly
you can use
the subtraction operator
and you can change the Alias name as
let's say subtract
let's run it
you get minus 10. now there are some
basic inbuilt functions there are a lot
of inbuilt functions in SQL but here
I'll show you a few
suppose you want to find the length of a
text or a string you can use the length
function
so I'll write select and then use the
length function I'll hit tab to auto
complete let's say I want to find the
length of country India
and I'll give an alias as total length
if I run it
you see here it returns 5 because there
are five letters
in India
there is another function called repeat
so let me show you how repeat works
so I'll write select
repeat
let's say I want to repeat the symbol
that is at the rate
I'll put it in single course because it
is a text character and I want to repeat
this character for 10 times
close the bracket
and let's run it
you can see here in the output it has
printed at the rate 10 times you can
count it
all right
now let's say you want to convert a text
or a string to uppercase or lowercase
you can do that as well
so I'll write select and use the
function called upper
let's say I want to convert
my string that is India to upper case I
am not giving in any Alias name
if I run this
see my input was capital I and
everything else was in small letter
in the output you can see it is
converted
my input to all caps
similarly you can change this
let's say you want to print something in
lower case you can use the lower
function
let's say
this time everything is in
upper case if I run it
it converts India to lowercase
now let's explore a few date and time
functions let's say you want to find the
current date there is a function called
Cur which stands for current
and this is the function I'm talking
about which is current date
if I run this you will get the current
date
that is 28th of Jan 2021
and let's say you want to extract the
day from a date value
so you can use the day function let's
say I'll use day and I want to find the
day from my current date
if I run this
you get 28 which is today's date
now similarly you can also
display the current date and time so for
that you can use a function that is
called now
so this will return the current date and
time
you can see this is the date value and
then we have the current time
all right
and this brings us to the end of our
demo session so let me just scroll
through whatever we have learned so
first I showed you how you can see the
databases present in MySQL then we used
one of the databases and checked the
tables in it then we created another
database called SQL intro for our demo
purpose we use the database and then
we created this table called employee
details with
column names like name integer the sex
date of joints City and salary
I showed you the structure of the
database let me run this again so you
get an idea you can see this was the
structure of our table
then we went ahead and inserted a few
records so we inserted records for six
employees so you have
the employee name the age the gender the
date of join the city to which the
employee belongs to and the salary of
the employee
then we saw how you can use the select
statement and display all the columns
present in the table
we learned how you can
display the Unique city names
we learned how to use
different aggregate functions like count
average and sum
then we learned how you could display
specific columns from the table
we learned how to use where clause
then we used an R operator we learned
about in operator
the between operator
then we used an and operator to select
multiple
conditions
finally we learned about group by order
by and some basic SQL operations
now it's time to explore some string
functions in MySQL
so I have given a comment string
functions
first
let's say you want to convert a certain
string into upper case so I can write
select
the function I'll use is upper
and within this function you can pass in
the string let's say
I'll write India
if you want you can give an alias name
as let's say uppercase
I'll give a semicolon
and let's run it there you go so my
input was in sentence case and using the
upper function we have converted
everything into uppercase similarly let
me just copy this
and
I'll show you
if you want to convert a string into a
lowercase you can use the lower function
and run this you can see the result
everything is in lower case now of
course I need to change the Alias name
to lowercase
instead of using lower as the function
there is another function that MySQL
provides which is called the L case I'll
just edit this and write L case
and let's say I'll write
India in
uppercase
let's run it returns me the same result
cool
moving on
let's say you want to find the length of
a string you can use the character
length function
I'll write select
use the function character length
and I'm again going to pass in my
string as India as let's say total
length
let's run it this time I'm going to hit
Ctrl enter to run MySQL command
there you go
it has given us the right result which
is 5 because India has five characters
in it now these functions you can also
apply on a table
now let me show you how to do it let's
say we already have the students table
and you want to find the
length of
each of the student names
so here you can pass
Stu underscore name
and you can give the same Alias name
let's say total length
and then you can write from
table name that is students
if I run this
you can see the output it has given me
total 20 rows of information this is not
readable actually let me also
display these student names so that we
can compare their
length
all right
I'll run this again
and now you can
see the result so Joseph has six
characters nilis as six Whipple has five
and above has seven similarly if you see
Akshay has six tennis has seven Raga
West 6.
has six so on and so forth
now instead of using this character
length you can also use the function
care length
it will work the same way let's see the
result
there you go it has given us the same
result you can either use character
length or care length
so there's another very interesting
function called concat so the concat
function adds two or more Expressions
together let's say I'll write select
use the function
concatenate
the function is actually concat
and I am going to pass in
my
string values let's say India
is
in Asia
let's run this and see our result
you can see here it has concatenated
everything
let us make it more readable I'll give a
space in between so that
you can read it clearly now this is much
more readable India is in Asia
and if you want you can give an alias
name as well as let's say merged
there you go
now the same concat operation you can
also perform on a table
I'm going to use the same students table
let's say I want to return the student
ID
followed by the student name
and then
I am going to merge
the student name
followed by a space
followed by the age of the student
and I can give an alias as let's say
name underscore each
from my table that is students
let's see how this works
okay you see here the result is very
clear
we have the student ID the student name
and the concatenated column that we
created which was name underscore each
where we have the
student name with a space followed by
the age of the student
if I scroll down you can see the rest of
the results
cool
now moving ahead
let's see how the reverse function Works
in MySQL
so the MySQL reverse function returns a
string with the characters printed in
reverse order
so suppose I write select
reverse
I'll use the same string again let's say
I have
India
let's run it you will see all the
characters printed in reverse order
again you can perform the same operation
on
a table as well let's say I'll write
select
reverse
and I'll pass in the column as student
name
from my table that is students
let's run it
it gives you 20 students and all the
names have been printed in reverse order
okay
now
let's see what the replace function does
so the replace function replaces all
occurrences of a substring within a
string within a new substring so let me
show you what I mean
I'll write select
replace
I'll pass in my input stream which is
let's say orange is a
vegetable
which is ideally incorrect I am
purposely writing this so that I can
replace the
word vegetable
with
fruit
okay
so what this replace function does is it
is going to find where my word vegetable
is within the string my input string and
it is going to replace my word vegetable
with fruit
let's run it and see the output there
you go now this is correct which is
Orange is a fruit
all right
now
MySQL also provides some trim functions
you can use the left trim right trim and
just the trim function
so let me show you how this
left trim box
left rim or L trim removes the leading
space characters from a string passed as
an argument
so say I write select
I'll use the left trim function which is
L trim
and then I am going to purposely give a
few speeches
in the beginning of the string I'll give
a word let's say India
and then I'll give some space after the
word India
and see how the
Ultram box if I run this it gives me
India which is fair enough
but before that
let's first find the length of my string
so I'll use my length function here
and within this function I am going to
find the length of my string which has
India along with some
leading and trailing spaces I'll paste
this here
and I'll run it
okay so the entire string is
17 characters long or the length of the
string is
17. now see I use l trim on my same
string foreign
and if I
run length over it you can see the
difference
as in you can see how many spaces were
deleted from the left of the string you
can see here now it says 17
and
I'm going to use l trim
let's see the difference it gives me 12
the reason being it has deleted
five spaces from the left you can count
it
one two three four and five so 17 minus
5 is
12 which is correct similarly you can
use the r trim function which removes
the trailing spaces from a string
trailing spaces are these spaces
when you use left Rim it deletes the
leading spaces which is this
now let me just replace L trim with r
trim which stands for right trim and see
the result
so the length is 10 now the reason being
it has deleted
seven spaces from the right of the
string if you can count it one two three
four five six and seven
cool
you can also
use the trim function which will delete
both the leading and the trailing spaces
so here if I just write trim
and I'll
run it
it gives me five
because India is total five characters
long and it has deleted all the leading
and the trailing spaces
all right
there's also a function called position
in MySQL the position function Returns
the position of the first occurrence of
a substring in a string so if the
substring is not found with the original
string the function will return 0.
so let's say I'll write select
position
I want to find
where
fruit is
in my string that is
Orange
is
a fruit
I'll give an alias as name
the sum error here
it should be within double quotes
now let's run it and see the result okay
it says at the 13th place or at the 13th
position we have the word fruit in our
string which is Orange is a fruit
now the final function we are going to
see is called ASCII so the ASCII
function Returns the ASCII value for a
specific character let's say I write
select
ASCII of the letter small a
if I run this
it will give me the ASCII value which is
let's say you want to find the ASCII
value of
let's see the result
it gives me 52.
all right
in this session we are going to learn
two important SQL statements or Clauses
that are widely used that is grouped by
and having
first we'll understand the basics of
group by and having and then jump into
MySQL workbench to implement these
statements so let's begin first
what is Group by in SQL so the group by
statement or Clause groups records into
summary rows and returns one record for
each group it groups the rows with the
same group by item expressions and
computes aggregate functions for the
resulting group
a group by Clause is a part of Select
expression
in each group no two rows have the same
value for the grouping column or columns
now below
you can see the syntax of group by so
first we have the select statement and
Then followed by the column names that
we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition and next
we have the group by clause and here we
include the column names finally we have
the order by and the column names
now here is an example of the group by
Clause so we want to find the average
salary of employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee ID
the employee name the age of the
employee we have the gender the date on
which the employer joined the company
then we have the department to which
each of these employees belong to we
have the city to which the employees
belong to and then we have the salary in
dollars so actually we'll be using this
employees table on MySQL workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your SQL query with Group
by Clause would look like so we have
selected department and then we are
using an aggregate function that is evg
which is average and we have chosen the
salary column and here we have given an
alias name which is average underscore
salary which appears in the output you
can see here from employees and we have
grouped it by department so here in the
output you can see we have the
department means and the average salary
of the employees in each department
now let me take you to my MySQL
workbench where we will Implement group
buy and solve specific problems okay so
I am on my MySQL workbench so let me
make my connection first
I'll enter the password
so this will open MySQL editor
so first of all
let me check the databases that I have
so I'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay you can see we have a list of
databases here I am going to use my
SQL underscore intro database so I'll
write
use
SQL underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database I'll run it all right
now you can check the
tables that are present in SQL
underscore into database
if I write show tables you can see the
list of tables that are already present
in this database to do a demo and
understand Group by as well as having
let me first create an employee table
so I'll write create table
employees
next
I'll give my column name as employee
underscore ID which is
the ID for each employee
I'll give my data type as integer and
I'll assign
employee ID as my primary key
next I'll give employee underscore name
and my data type would be workar
I'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then I have
my gender column
I'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size of 1.
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
Department column as well this is going
to be of
and 20 will be the size
next
we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to
and finally we have the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
I'll write describe employees
you can see the structure of the table
so far
all right now it's time for us to insert
a few records into this employees table
so I'll write insert
into
employees
and I'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my EMP notepad and you can
see I have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
we'll paste it here
all right
let me go to the top and verify if
all the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information or the records
that are present in our employees table
I'll write select star from employees if
I run it you can see here
I have my employee ID the employee name
age gender
you have the city salary and in total we
have
instead 20 records
now
let me run a few SQL commands to check
how the structure of our table is
let's say I want to see the distant
cities that are present in our table
so I'll write select distinct City from
employees
if I run this
you see here there are total
eight different cities present in our
employee stable so we have Chicago the
Seattle Boston we have New York
Miami and Detroit as well
now let's see
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present so you can use distinct
Department
if I run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
names so we have sales marketing product
Tech I.T finance and HR
all right
now let me show you
another SQL command
now this is to use an aggregate function
so I want to find the average age of all
the employees from the table
so I can write select
AVG which is the aggregate function for
average
inside that I have passed my
each column from employees if I run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is 33.35
now
say you want to find the average age of
employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
I'll give a comment here I want to find
the
average age
in each department
so
I'll write select
Department
comma
I'll write average of age
from
employees
Group by
Department
now if I run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left and on the right you can see
the average age of employees in each of
these departments now you can see here
in the output it says AVG of age which
is not readable so I can give an alias
name as
average age
all right
I can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also
so you can round the decimal places so
I'll use a round function before the
average function
and the round function takes two
parameters one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if I run this
there you go you can see here we have
the average age of all the employees in
each of these departments
all right
now suppose you want to find the total
salary of all the employees for each
department so
you can write select
Department
comma
now I want the total salary so I'll use
the sum function
and I'll pass my column as salary
from
employees
Group by
Department
let's run this query
you can see here
in the output we have the different
departments and on the right you can see
the total salary of all the employees in
each of these departments now here also
you can give an alias name as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the output here
all right now moving ahead
you can also use the order by Clause
along with the group by Clause let's see
you want to find the total number of
employees in each City and group it in
the order of employee ID so
to do this I can use my select query
I'll write select
count of let's say employee ID
and I want to know the city as well
from
employees
Group by
City
and next you can use the order by clause
I'll write order by
count of
employee ID
and I'll write desc which stands for
descending
if I run this query
you can see here on the left you have
the account of employees and on the
right you can see the
city names so in Chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had Seattle Houston
Boston Austin
and the remaining also had two employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee ID
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that joined the company each
year we can use the year function on the
date of joining column then we can count
the employee IDs and group the result by
each year
so let me show you how to do it
so I'll write select
I am going to extract here from
the date of join column I'll give an
alias as year
next
I'll
count the
employee ID
from my table name that is employees
and
I am going to group it by
year
date of join
if I give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
grid you see here in the result we have
the year that we have extracted from the
data join column and on the right you
can see the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was one employee similarly we have
in 2009 there were two employees
if I scroll down you have information of
other years as well
now if you want you can order this as
well based on year or count
okay
now you can also use the group by to
join two or more tables together
so to show you this operation let me
first create a sales table
so I'll write create
table
sales
and the sales table will have columns
such as the product ID which is going to
be of integer type then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be a upload value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so I'll write
quantity
quantity will of integer type
next we have the state in which the item
was sold
and state I'll put it as worker and give
the sizes 20.
let's run this so that we'll create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so I've already written
the records in a notepad let me show you
okay so here you can see I have my sales
text file let me just copy these
information
I'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command all right so you can see
here we have successfully inserted nine
rows of information
so let me just run it through what we
have inserted
so the first
column is the product ID column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold then we have the
quantity that was sold and in which
state it was sold so we have California
Texas Alaska
then we have
another product ID which is one two
three
and these are the states in which the
products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement I'll write select star
from
sales
if I run this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose you want to find the revenue
for both the product IDs one to one and
let's say one two three since we have
just two product IDs here
so for that you can use the select query
so I'll write select
product ID
next I want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but selling price
multiplied by the quantity so I'll use
the sum function to find the total
revenue and inside the sum function I'll
use my
selling price column
multiplied by
quantity column
I'll give this
an alias name as Revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally I'll group it by
product ID
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product IDs one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated from these
two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products one to
one and one to three so for that I'll
create another table now this table will
have the cost price of
both the products so let me create the
table first
I'll write create table
let's say the table name is C product
which stands for the cost price of the
products
I'll
Give My First Column as product ID
this will be an integer
and I'll have my second column as cost
price
cost price will have floating type
values
let's run this so we have successfully
created our product cost table
now let me insert a few values into the
C product table so I'll write insert
into
C underscore
product
I'll give
my values
for one to one
let's see the
cost price was 200 and
170 dollars
for each
and next we have my product as one two
three and let's say the cost price for
product one two three was
250 dollars
let's insert these two values okay next
we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the products
so I'll write select
C Dot
product underscore ID
comma
I'll write sum
s dot cell underscore price now here C
and S are Alias names
so if I subtract my
cost price from the selling price that
will return the profit that was
generated
I'll multiply this with s dot
quantity
close the bracket
I'll give an alias name as
profit
from seals as s
so here s stands for the sales table
I am going to use inner join
C underscore
product table
as
the Alias name should be C
where
s dot
product underscore ID is equal to C Dot
product underscore ID we are using
product underscore ID because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
I am going to
group it by
C dot product underscore ID
all right
so let me tell you what I have done here
so I am selecting the product ID
next I am calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and I have multiplied the
quantity column
I'm using an inner join to connect my
sales and the
product cost table
and I am joining on the column that is
product ID and I have grouped it by C
dot product ID let's run this there you
go so here you can see for product ID
one to one
we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars
and for product ID 123 we made a profit
of eight hundred and forty dollars so
now that we have learned Group by in
detail let's learn about the having
clause in SQL the having clause in SQL
operates on grouped records and returns
rows where aggregate function results
matched with given conditions only
so now having and where Clause are kind
of similar but where Clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
Clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the WHERE
conditions next we have the group by
finally we have having and at last we
have order by column names so you can
see here we have a question at hand we
want to find the cities where there are
more than two employees
so you can see the employee table that
we had used in our
Group by Clause as well so if you were
to find the cities where there are more
than two employees so this is how your
SQL queries should look like so we have
selected
the employee ID and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
City And then we have user having clause
so we have given our condition having
count of employee ID should be greater
than two so if you see the output we
have the different city names and these
were the cities where the
count of employees was greater than 2.
all right so let's go to our MySQL
workbench and Implement how having works
so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000 you can use the having clause for
this so let me first run my table which
is employees
if I run this you can see we had
inserted 20 rows of information and
the last column we had was salary so the
question we have is we want to find
those departments where the average
salary is greater than 75 000 dollars
so let me show you how to do it
so I'll write select
Department comma
I'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary
I'll give an alias name as
AVG
underscore salary
from
employees
next we'll use the
Group by clause and I want to group it
by each department
and then I am going to write my having
Clause so in having Clause I'll use my
condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
75 000 dollars
let's run it
and see the output
there you go so here you can see there
were total three departments in the
company that is sales Finance in HR
where the average salary is greater than
75 000 dollars
okay
next let's say you want to find the
cities where the total salary is greater
than two hundred thousand dollars
so
this will again be a simple
SQL query so I'll write select City
comma
I want to find the total salary so I'll
use the sum function
and I'll pass my column as salary as
I'll give a
Alias name as total from
employees
Group by
City
and then I am going to use my having
clause
I'll pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right
so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are Chicago
Seattle and Houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the Departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
I'll write select
Department comma
this time since I want to find the
number of employees I am going to use
the count function I'll write count Star
as
employee underscore count or EMP
underscore count which is my Alias name
from
employees
next I'll group it by
Department
having
I'll give my condition
count star greater than 2.
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product Tech and ID where
there are more than two employees
okay now you can also use a where Clause
along with the having clause in an SQL
statement
so suppose I want to find the cities
that have more than two employees apart
from Houston
so
I can write my query as select
City comma
count star
as
EMP count
from
employees
where
I'll give my condition shitty
not equal to
Houston I'll put it in double quotes
since I don't want to see
the information regarding Houston
I'll group it by
City
having
count
of employees greater than 2.
so if I run this query
you see we have information for Chicago
and Seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
Houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having Clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if I want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75 000 I
can write it something like this
so select
Department
comma
count
star
as
EMP count
from
employees
Group by
Department
and in the having clause
I am going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so I'll write having
average salary
greater than 75 000.
this is another way to use the having
Clause let's run this
all right you can see we have department
sales finance and HR and you can see the
employee count where the average salary
was greater than 75 000.
okay
so let me run you from the beginning
what we did in our demo so first we
created a table called employee then we
inserted 20 records to this table
next we explored a few SQL commands like
distinct then we used average and
finally we started with our
Group by clause
followed by
looking at how Group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and product
cost stable to find out the profit
then you learned how to use the having
clause
so we explored several different
questions and learned how to use
having an SQL and to get ahead with this
successful career simply an offers post
graduate program in full stack web
development with this amazing program
you will be benefited with Caltech ctme
postgraduate certificate receive up to
25 CEUs and caltex ctme attend master
classes from Caltech ctma instructors
live virtual classes led by industry
experts Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs by the end of this course you will
be skilled with agile Java hibernet and
jpa spring core 50 HTML5 and css3 AWS
JavaScript and there is used list on the
board expertise and tools like angular
css3 Docker git HTML5 Jenkins mongodb
and MySQL will add value to your resume
so hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box in this session we
will learn about joins in SQL joints are
really important when you have to deal
with data that is present on multiple
tables
I'll help you understand the basics of
joints and make you learn the different
types of joints with Hands-On
demonstrations on MySQL workbench so
let's get started with what are joints
in SQL
SQL join statement or command is often
used to fetch data present in multiple
tables SQL joints are used to combine
rows of data from two or more tables
based on a common field or column
between them now consider this example
where we have two tables an order stable
and a customer stable
now the order table has information
about the order ID which is unique here
we have the order date
that is when the order was placed then
we have the shift date this has
information about the date on which the
order was shipped then we have the
product name which basically is the
names of different products we have the
status of delivery whether the product
was delivered or not or whether it was
canceled then we have the quantity which
means the number of products that were
ordered and finally we have the price of
each product
similarly
we have another table called customers
and this customer table has information
about the order ID
which is the foreign key here
then we have the customer ID which is
the primary key for this table we also
have the phone number customer name and
address of the customers
now suppose you want to find the phone
numbers of customers who have ordered a
laptop
now to solve this problem
we need to join both the tables the
reason being the phone numbers are
present in the customers table as you
can see here
and laptop which is the product name is
present in the order stable which you
can see it here so using a join
statement you can find the phone numbers
of customers who have ordered a laptop
now let's see another problem where you
need to find the customer name so have
ordered a product in the last 30 days in
this case we want the customer name
present in the customers table and the
last 30 days order information which you
can get from the order date column that
is present in the order stable
okay now let's discuss the different
types of joints one by one so first we
have an inner join
so the SQL inner join statement returns
all the rows from multiple tables as
long as the conditions are met
from the diagram above you can see that
there are two tables A and B A is the
left table and B is the right table
the orange portion represents the output
of an inner join
which means an inner join Returns the
common records from both the tables
now you can see the syntax here so we
have the select command and then
we give the list of columns from table a
which you can see here is the left table
followed by the inner join keyword and
then the name of the table
that is B on a common key column from
both the tables A and B now let me take
you to the MySQL workbench and show you
how inner join Works in reality
so here I'll type MySQL
you can see I have got my SQL workbench
8.0 version installed I'll click on it
will take some time to open
okay
I'll click on this local instance
and here I'll give my password
okay
so this is how an SQL editor on MySQL
workbench looks like
so first of all
let me go ahead and create a new
database so I'll write
create
database this is going to be my command
followed by the name of the database
that is going to be SQL underscore joins
if I give a semicolon and hit Ctrl enter
this will create a new database you can
see here one row affected
now
you can check whether the database was
created or not using show databases
command
if I run it
here you can see I have
SQL joints database
created
now I'll use this database so I'll write
use SQL underscore joins
okay now to understand inner join
consider that there is a college
and in every College you have different
teams for different sports such as
Cricket football basketball and others
so let's create two tables cricket and
football
so I'll write
create
table
and my table name is going to be cricket
next
I am going to create two columns
in this table the First Column is going
to be cricket
ID
then
I'm going to give the data type as int
and use the auto increment operator I am
using Auto increment because my Cricut
ID is going to be my primary key
then I'm going to give
the name of the students who are part of
the cricket team
and for this I'll use varka data type
and give the length as 30
I'll give another comma and
I'll assign my Cricut ID as primary key
within brackets I'll give
Cricket underscore ID
Cricket ID is nothing but a unique
identifier for each of the players like
you have roll numbers in college
okay
let me just run it
all right so we have successfully
created our Cricut table
similarly let me just copy this and I'll
paste it here
I'll create
another table called football
this will have the information of all
the students who are part of the
football team
and instead of Cricut I am going to give
this as football ID
all right
and
the name column will have the names of
the students I'll change my primary key
to football ID
all right let me run this okay so now we
have also created our
football table the next step is to
insert a few player names into both the
tables
so I'll write my insert into command
first let's load some data to our Cricut
table
so I'll write cricket and
I'll give my
name column
followed by
values and here I'll give some names
such as
let's say Stuart
we have another comma
the next player I'll choose is let's say
Michael
similarly I'll add a few more let's say
we have
Johnson
the fourth player I'll take is let's say
hidden
and finally we have
lots of Fleming
okay
now I'll give a semicolon and run this
okay so let me just check if all the
values were inserted properly for this
I'll use
select star from table that is Cricket
if I run it you can see I have created a
table and have successfully inserted
five rows of information
now similarly
let's insert
a few student names
for our football table so I'll change
this to
football
and obviously there would be students
who will be part of both cricket and
football team so
I'll keep a few
repeated names let's say Stuart
Johnson and let's say hidden are part of
both cricket and football team
then we have let's say
Langer and
let's say we have another player in the
football team that is Aston
I'll just run it okay you can see there
are no errors so we have successfully
inserted values to our football team as
well
let me just recheck it
I'll write select star from
football
all right so we have five players in the
football team as well okay
now the question is suppose you want to
find the students that are part of both
the cricket and football team in this
case you can use an inner join
so let me show you how to do it
so I'll write select star from
cricket
as I'm using an alias name as C which
stands for Cricket
then I am going to write inner join
my next table is going to be football
as F which is an alias name for the
football table
then I am going to use the on
command or operator
and then
I'll give the common
key that is name here so C dot name is
equal to F dot name
So based on this name column from both
the table my inner Zone operation will
be performed so let's just run it
there you go so Stuart Johnson and
Hayden are the only three students who
are part of both the teams
all right
now you can also individually select
each of the columns from both the tables
so let's say I write select C Dot
Cricut underscore IDE comma
C dot name
comma F Dot
football underscore ID
comma F dot name
from
I'll write
Cricket as C
inner join
football as F on
C dot name
is equal to F dot name
now if I run this you see we get the
same output here as well
all right
now let's explore another example to
learn more about inner joins so we have
a database called classic models let me
first
use classic models
I'll run this okay now let me just show
the different tables that are part of
classic tables
all right
so here you can see there are tables
like customers there's employees office
there's office details
orders payments products and product
lines as well
all right
so
let me use
my select statement to show
what are the columns present in the
products table
okay so this product table has
information about different
product names you have the product code
now this product code is unique here
we also have the product vendor
a little description about the product
then we have the quantity in stock
buying price and MSRP
let's see what we have in
product lines
if I run it you see here we have the
product line which is the
primary key for this table then we have
the textual description for each of the
products this is basically some sort of
an advertisement
all right now suppose
you want to find the product code the
product name and the text description
for each of the products you can join
the products and product lines table
so let me show you how to do it
I'll write my select statement and
choose my columns as product code then
we have
product name
and let's say I want the text
description so I'll write this column
name
okay
then I'll use from
my first table that is
products
inner join
product lines
I can use using
the common key column that is product
line
close the bracket I'll give a semicolon
and if I run it there you go so you can
see the different product codes then we
have the different product names and the
textual description for each of the
products so this we did by joining the
products table and the product line
stable
all right
now suppose you want to find the revenue
generated from each product order and
the status of the product to do this
task we need to join three tables that
is orders order details and products so
first let me show you
what are the columns we have in these
three tables we have obviously seen for
the products table now let me show you
for orders and Order details table
so I'll write select star from orders
if I run it you can see it has
information about the order number
the date on which the order was placed
we also have the shipment date we also
have the status column which has
information regarding whether the order
was shipped or canceled
then we have some comments column we
also have the customer number who
ordered this particular product
similarly let's check what we have under
order details
so I'll write select star from
order details if I run it
you can see it has the order number the
product code quantity of each product we
have the price of each product then we
have the order line number okay
so using the product
orders and Order details less perform an
inner join
so I'll write select
O DOT
order number
comma
O DOT status
I need the product name which I'll take
from the products table so I'll write P
Dot
product name now here o p are all
Alias name for the tables orders
products and I'll use OD for order
details
comma
since we want to find the revenue
we actually need to
find the product of quantity ordered
into
price of each product so I'll use a sum
function and inside the sum function
I'll give
quantity
ordered
multiplied by
the price of each item
I'll use an alias as Revenue
then I'll use my from clause
from orders as o
inner join
order
details as I'll use an alias name as OD
on
I'll write
O DOT
order number
is equal to
OD Dot
order number
I'll use another inner join
and this time we'll join the products
table so I'll write inner join products
as
p on
P Dot
product code
is equal to
OD Dot
product code
and finally I'll use the group by clause
and group it by order number
all right
let me run this
okay there's some mistake here we need
to debug this
it says
you have an error in your SQL syntax
check the manual all right okay I think
the name of the tables is actually
orders or not order
all right now let's run it
okay there's still some error
it says
classic models dot product doesn't exist
so again the product name is
I mean the table name is products and
not product so let's run it again all
right there you go so we have the order
number the status
the product name and the revenue
this we got it using
inner join from three different tables
now talking about left joins
the SQL left join statement returns all
the rows from the left table and the
matching rows from the right table so if
you see this diagram you can see we have
all the rows from the left table that is
a and only the matching rows from the
right table that is B so you can see
this
overlapped region
and the syntax
for SQL left join is something like this
so you have the select statement and
then you give the list of columns from
table a which is your left table then
you use the left join keyword
followed by the next table that is table
B on the common key column so you write
a DOT key is equal to B dot key
okay now in our classic models database
we have two tables customers and orders
so if you want to find the customer name
and their order ID you can use these two
tables so first let me show you the
columns that are present in
customers and orders
I think orders we have already seen let
me first show you
what's there in the customers table okay
so you can see we have the customer
number the name of the customer then we
have the contact last name the contact
first name we have the phone number then
there's an address column there are two
address columns actually
we have the city name the state
and we have other
information as well and similarly we
have our order stable so I'll write
select start form
orders so I'll write select star from
orders
if I run this you can see these are the
information available in the
orders table
okay so let's perform a left join
where we want to find the customer name
and their order IDs so I'll write select
C Dot
customer name
or let's say first we'll choose the
customer number comma
then I want the customer name so I'll
write C Dot customer name
then we have the
order number column which is present in
the orders table and let's say I also
want to see the status
then I'll give my left table that is
customers
as C
left join
orders as o
on
C Dot
customer number equal to
O DOT customer number
let's run it
okay again there is some problem
all right so the table name is customers
let's run it
so there's another mistake here this is
customer number so B is missing cool let
me run it all right so here you can see
we have the information regarding the
customer number
then
the respective customer names we have
the order number and the
status of the shipment so if I scroll
down you'll notice one thing there are a
few rows you can see which have null
values this means for customer number
125 and for this particular customer
name there were no orders
and similarly if I scroll down you will
find a few more null values
you can see here there are two null
values here for
customer number 168 and 169 there were
no orders available
all right now to check those customers
who haven't placed any orders
you can use the null operator so what
I'll do is here I'll just continue with
this I'll use a where clause and write
where
order
number is null
now let me run this
okay so here you can see there are
24 customers from the table that don't
have any orders in their names
okay now talking about right joints so
SQL right join statement returns all the
rows from the right table and only
matching rows from the left table so
here you can see we have our left table
as a and the right table as B so the
right join will return all the rows from
the right table and only the matching
rows from the left table
now talking about the syntax so here you
can see we have the select statement
followed by the select statement you
will have the list of columns that you
want to choose
from table a right join table B on the
common key column from both the tables
all right
now to show how right join works I'll be
using two tables that is customers and
employees so let's see
the rows of data that are present in the
customer table first so I'll write
select star from
customers
let's run it so here you have the
customer number the customer name
then we have the phone number the
address of the customers
you also have the country to which the
customer belongs to the postal code
and the credit limit as well similarly
let's see for
the employees table
here I'll change customers to employees
let's run it okay so we have the
employee number the last name the first
name we have the extension the email ID
the job title
and also
reports to here means the manager
okay
So based on these two tables we'll find
the customer name the phone number of
the customer and the email address of
the employee and join both the tables
that is customers and employees
so let me show you the command so I'll
write select
C Dot
customer name comma
then we have C Dot
phone I'll give a space here
next I want
the employee number from the employee
table so I'll write e Dot
employee number comma e dot email from
customers as C
right join
employees
as e
on
e Dot my common key column is employee
number here so I'll write e Dot employee
number is equal to
C Dot
we have
sales
Representatives
employee number
and I'm also going to order it by
the employee number column
okay
so you can see I have my customer name
selected from the customers table the
phone number of the customer then we
have the employee number and the email
address so let me run it
okay there's some problem
all right so the table name is customers
actually
let's run it once again
there you go so you can see here
we have
all the values selected from our right
table which is the employees table you
can see write Zone employees which means
your employee stable is to the right
and then we have the customer name and
phone numbers of
the customers from the customer table
which is actually your left table so you
have a few
employee numbers such as one zero zero
two this one zero five six we don't have
any customer name or phone numbers
okay so there's another popular join
which is very widely used in SQL known
as cell joins so self joints are used to
join a table to itself
so in our database we have a table
called employees let me show you the
table first
all right
so here you can see we have the employee
number the last name the first name of
the employee we have the email ID
and here if you see we have a column
called reports two now this you can
think of as the manager column so the
way to read is for example
for employee number 1056
the manager is one zero zero two so if
you check for one zero zero two we have
day in Murphy
then if I scroll down
let's see for employee number
yeah for employee number 1102 the
manager is one zero five six so here you
can see who is at one zero five six you
have
Mary Patterson
similarly if I scroll down let's say
for employee number 1188
we have
the manager as one one
four three now if I check the table at
one one four three we have Anthony bow
so so the employee Julie farrelli
reports to Anthony Bowe
all right
now suppose you want to know who is the
reporting manager for each employee so
for that you can use a self join so let
me show you how to join this employees
table
I'll write select
and then I am going to use a function
called concat
within brackets I'll start with my Alias
name that is m dot
then I'll write last name
I am going to concat last name
followed by a comma
then I'll have my first name
I'll close this bracket and then I'm
going to give my
Alias name let's say manager
comma next I am going to concat
the same
last name and first name and this time
I'm going to use a separate Alias let's
say e which stands for employee so I'll
write e dot last name comma and within
single quotes
I'll
give my comma and then I'll write e DOT
first name
I close this bracket I'll give an alias
as let's say
employee
from
I'll write
employees
as e
inner join
employees
as m on
m dot
I'll use my common key column as
employee number so I'll write
m dot
employee number is equal to
e dot here I am going to use the reports
to column
and then
I'll
order it by
let's say manager
okay
now let's run this
there you go so you have your two
columns as manager and employee so for
employee Louis bonder
the manager is zeradbander
similarly if I scroll down
you have there are multiple employees
reporting to this particular manager
similarly we have our manager as
anthonybo and we have
different employees who are reporting to
this particular manager and so on
all right now moving ahead
now let's see what a full join is so SQL
full outer join statement returns all
the rows when there is a match in either
left or right table now you must
remember that MySQL workbench does not
support full auto join by default but
there's a way to do it so by default
this is how the syntax of full outer
join looks like
now this statement will work on other
SQL databases like Microsoft SQL server
but it won't work on MySQL workbench
I'll show you the right way of using
full auto join on MySQL workbench
so to show full outer join I am going to
first use a left join and then we'll
also use a right join and finally we'll
use a union operator so the union
operator is used to combine the result
set of two or more select statements
so first of all let me write
C Dot
customer name so for this example I'm
using the customer table and the order
table
comma O DOT
order number so I just want to know the
customer name and the order number
related to the customer
from
I have
customers
as
C
left join
I'll write
orders as o
on
C Dot
customer number
is equal to
O DOT
customer number
let me just copy this
and after this I am going to use my
union operator
so Union operator is used to merge
results from
two or more
tables
so basically this performs a vertical
join
and next I am going to use my right join
operation so here instead of left join
I'll write write
restore looks fine
let me just run it
there you go so we have successfully run
our full outer join operation you can
see we have the different customer names
and
the order that each customer had placed
all right
so that brings us to the end of our demo
session so let me just run through
whatever we did in this session so first
we created a database called SQL joints
then we created two tables like cricket
and football
then we had
inserted a few
rows to each of these tables then we
used this table to learn about inner
join
next
we used a database called classic models
it had multiple tables so we explored
all of these tables like products
service product lines orders customers
and employees and learned how to use
inner join left join self join right
join as well as full outer join in this
video
we will learn what is a sub query and
look at the different types of sub
queries
then we learn some queries with select
statement followed by sub queries with
insert statement moving further we will
learn sub queries with the update
statement and finally we look at sub
queries with delete statement all this
we will be doing on our MySQL workbench
so before I begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply learn Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so
let's start with what is a sub query
so a sub query is a select query that is
enclosed inside another query
so if I show you
this is how
the basic structure of a sub query looks
like so here whatever is present inside
the brackets is called as the inner
query and whatever is present outside is
called the outer query
so first the inner query gets executed
and the result is returned to the outer
query and then the outer query operation
is performed
all right now let's see an example so we
have a question at hand which is to
write a SQL query to display Department
with maximum salary from employee stable
so this is how our employee stable looks
like it has the employee ID the employee
name each gender we have the date of
joint Department City and salary
now to solve this query
my sub query would look like this
so I'll first select the department from
my table that is employees where
I'll use the Condition salary equal to
and then I'll pass in my inner query
which is Select Max of salary from
employees so what this does is it will
first return the maximum salary of the
employees in the table
then a router query will get executed
based on the salary return from the
inner query
so here the output is
department sales has the maximum salary
so one of the employees from the sales
department earns the highest or the
maximum salary if you see in our table
the employee is Joseph who owns hundred
and fifteen thousand dollars all right
and Joseph is from the sales department
now let's see how this query works so
here we have another question which is
to find the name of the employee with
maximum salary in the employees table so
this is our previous employees table
that we saw and to find the employee who
has the maximum salary
my sub query would look something like
this so I'm selecting the employee name
from my table that is employees where I
am using the Condition salary equal to
and then I'm passing in my sub query or
the inner query so first I am selecting
the maximum salary
this will return a particular value that
is the highest salary from the table
and if you see our table the highest
salary is hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars
so our query becomes select employee
name from employees with salary equal to
115 000 so the employee name is Joseph
here and
that's the output now if you want to
break it down
here you can see first the inner query
gets executed so our SQL query will
first execute the
inner query that is present inside
brackets select maximum salary from
employees the result is hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars and then based
on the returned result our outer query
gets executed so the query becomes
select employee name from employees
where salary equal to hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars and that
employees Joseph
all right
now we'll learn the different types of
sub queries so you can write sub queries
using select statement update statement
delete and insert statement we'll
explore each of this with the help of
example on my MySQL workbench
so let's learn some queries with the
select statement
so sub queries are majorly used with the
select statement and this is how the
syntax looks like you select the column
name from the table name then you have
the
where condition followed by The Columns
that you want to pass the operator and
inside that
you have this sub query so here is an
example that we will perform on our
MySQL workbench so in this example we
want to select all the employees who
have a salary less than average salary
for all the employees
this is the output so let's do this on
my MySQL workbench
all right so let me log into my local
instance
I'll give my password
okay so you can see I am on my MySQL
workbench so let's start by
writing a sub query using the
select statement
okay so for this demo session we'll be
using a database that is sub queries you
can see it here I have a database called
sub queries
so I'll
use this
sub queries database
and we'll create a few tables as well
okay
now if I run it
now we are inside the sub queries
database
so
so let me just show you the tables that
are present inside this database I'll
write show tables
if I run it
okay there are two tables employees and
employees underscore B we'll use this
table throughout our demo session
all right
now for our select sub query we want to
fetch the employee name the department
and the salary
whose salary is less than the average
salary so we will be using the employees
table so let me first show you
the records and the columns we have in
the employees table
so I'll write select start from
employees and run it okay you can see
here we have 20 rows of information
we have the employee name the employee
ID age gender joint Department City and
salary so this is the same table that we
saw in our slides
okay
now for our sub query I'll write select
I want to choose the employee name
the department
and the salary
there should be a comma here instead of
a period
next I'll give my table name that is
employees
where
my salary is less than and after this
I'll start my inner query or the sub
query I'll write select
average salary so I'm using the AVG
function to find the average salary of
all the
employees
from my table that is employees
if I give a semicolon
and run this
you'll see the output
so we have total 12 employees in the
table whose salary is less than the
average salary now if you want you can
check the average salary
so the average salary is 75 350 dollars
now the employees who have a salary less
than the average salary
so these are the people
all right
now moving back to our slides
okay
now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the insert statement
now the insert statement uses the data
written from the sub query to insert
into another table
so this is how the syntax looks like so
you write insert into table name
followed by select individual column so
start from the table use the where
clause and then you give the operator
followed by the inner query or the sub
query
so here
we will explore a table called products
table
we are going to fetch few records from
the products table based on a condition
that is the selling price of the product
should be greater than 100 so only those
records will fetch and put it in our
order stable all right
so we are going to write this query on
my MySQL workbench so let's do it
I'll give my
comment as
update sub query
all right
so first of all let's create a table
that is
products so I'll write create table
products
then we'll give our column names the
First Column would be the product ID of
type integer
then we have the column as item or the
product
which is of type worker 30
next we have the
selling price of that product the
selling price will be of type float
and finally we have another
column which is called the product type
and again product type is of
the data type worker I'll give the size
as 30.
close the bracket and give a semicolon
now let's just run it
okay so we have successfully created our
products table
now let's insert a few records to our
so I'll write insert into
products
followed by values
I'll give
four records the first product ID is one
zero one
the product is
let's say jewelry
then the selling price is let's say
eight hundred dollars and the product
type is it's a luxury product
next let's insert one more product
detail the product ID is one zero two
the product
is let's say t-shirt
the price is let's say hundred dollars
and the product type is
non luxury
[Music]
next
I'll just copy this
to reduce our task
we'll edit this
the third product's ID is one zero three
the product is laptop
and let's say the price is thirteen
hundred dollars
and it's a luxury product
I'll paste again and finally I'll enter
my fourth product
which is let's say
table
and the price is
four hundred dollars and it's a
non-luxury product
I'll give a semicolon and we'll insert
these four records to our products table
you can see
we have inserted four records let's just
print it now so I'll write
select
star from
products
if I run it
you can see we have our four products
ready
now
we need to create another table where we
are going to put some records
from our products table so that new
table is going to be the orders table so
I'll write create
table
orders
now it will have three columns the
order ID
order ID will be of type integer then we
have
product
underscore sold
this would be of type
varying character of size 30 and finally
we have the
selling price column
this will be of type float
let's create our orders table
the table name should be orders and
there is some mistake here okay
so close the brackets okay
let me run it
so we have our order stable ready
now
let's write our
insert subquery
so I am going to insert
into
my table that is
orders
and I'll select
the product ID
comma the item
and the selling price or the sale price
from
my table that is products
where
I'll write
product ID
in
I'll write my inner query select
prod ID or the product ID
from
products
next I'll give a where Clause where
the selling price
is greater than one thousand dollars
so let me tell you what I am going to do
here I am going to insert into my order
stable
the product ID the item name and the
selling price from my products table
where
the product ID
has this condition so let me first run
this condition for you which is Select
broad ID from products where the selling
price is greater than 1000 if I run this
okay there is some issue here
the column name is actually prod ID
now let's run it again so that we can
see the product IDs of the products
which have a selling price greater than
1000 so it is one zero one and one zero
three now let's run the entire query
there is another mistake here let's
debug the mistake
now this should be product ID instead of
product underscore in
let's insert again all right so we have
successfully inserted two records to our
table that is orders now let's see the
order stable I'll write select star from
orders
if I run it there you go so there were
two products from a product table that
were jewelry and laptop which have a
selling price greater than one thousand
dollars so the selling price for jewelry
was 1800 and for laptop it was
thirteen hundred dollars so this is how
you can use a sub query using the insert
statement all right now going back to
our slides again
all right
now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the update statement
now the sub queries can be used in
conjunction with the update statement so
either single or multiple columns in a
table can be updated when using a sub
query with the updates statement
so this is how the basic syntax of an
update sub query looks like so you write
update table followed by the table name
you set the column name you give the
where operator and then you write your
inner sub query
so we are going to see an example
where we will use this employee stable
and using this employee stable we will
update the records of the salaries of
the employees
by multiplying it with a factor of 0.35
only for those employees which have age
greater than 27 so we are going to use a
new table called employees underscore B
for this as well so let's see how to do
it
so I'll give my comment as
update sub query
before we see the sub query let's see
what we have in the table employees
underscore B
this is basically a replica of the
employees table
there you go it has the same records
that our employees table has we are
going to use both the employees table
and the employees underscore B table to
update our records
so I'll write
update
employees
set
salary equal to
let me bring this to the next line
I'll write set salary equal to
salary
multiplied by point
three five
where
age
in
then I'll write select
each from
my other table that is
employees underscore B
where
age is greater than equal to
let's say 27.
all right
so let me run through this query and
tell you what we are going to do so I am
going to update the records of the
employees table specifically for the
salary column so I'm checking if the age
is greater than 27 then will multiply
the salaries of the employees with a
factor of 0.35 in the employees table
let me just run this then we'll see our
output
okay so it says 18 rows affected which
means there are total 18 employees in
the table out of the 20 employees whose
ages greater than 27 now if you see I'll
write select star from
employees
you can see the difference in the
salaries
if I scroll to the right you can see
these are the updated salaries
okay
now if you check for employees who have
an each
less than or equal to 27
for example Marcus whose age is 25 his
salary is the same we haven't updated
his salary then if you see
if we have okay there is one more
employee Maya
we haven't updated the salary of Maya
because the age is less than
27.
all right
now let's go back to our slides again
as you can see we got the same output on
our MySQL workbench
now let's explore how you can write sub
queries with the delete statement
now sub queries can again be used in
conjunction with the delete statement so
this is how the basic syntax of a delete
query using sub query would look like
you write delete from the table name
where Clause the operator value followed
by the inner query in within brackets
so here we are going to use the
employees table and what we are going to
do is we'll delete the employees whose
ages greater than equal to 27. so let's
see how you can do it
all right so I'll
keep my comment
as
delete sub query
so we'll follow the syntax that we saw
I'll write delete
from
my table name that is employees
I'll write where
each
in and then I'll start my inner query or
the sub query I'll write select each
from
employees underscore B
where
age is let's say
greater than equal to
32 or let's say the age is less than
equal to 32
close the bracket and I'll give my
semicolon let me first run the inner
query for you so that you get an idea of
the employees who are less than 32 years
of age
so there are nine employees in the table
who have an age less than equal to 32 so
we are going to delete the records
if I run this
okay it says nine records deleted
now let's
print or display what we have
in the employees table
if I run this
there you go so if you see the age table
we have total 11 employees now and all
their ages are greater than
32 because we have deleted all those
employees who had an h less than equal
to 32. okay
so
let me show you from the beginning what
we did so first we used our sub queries
database then we used our employees
table
so we started by looking at how you can
use the sub query
with a select statement this should be
insert instead of update
so we learned how to write an insert sub
query
we use two tables products and our order
stable
moving ahead we saw how to write
sub queries using the update command
so we updated the salaries of the
employee by a factor of 0.35 for those
who had an each greater than equal to 27
and finally we saw how to use the sub
query using the delete statement so we
deleted all those records for the
employees whose age was less than equal
to 32 in this video we will discuss an
advanced SQL concept called triggers
we will learn what triggers are and how
they can be used to solve problems
we look at how trigger queries are
written on MySQL workbench so let's get
started first what are triggers in SQL
so a trigger is a user-defined SQL
command that is invoked automatically
when an event occurs and event can be
related to inserting updating or
deleting records in a table
in MySQL triggers can be executed
automatically by the Oracle server
below is how the syntax of writing a
trigger is
so you write create trigger followed by
the trigger name now the trigger name
should be a valid SQL name then we have
the trigger time
the trigger event and then on the name
of the table then we write for each row
begin followed by the list of skill
statements and finally we write end
now in the syntax the trigger time
represents either before or after an
event
and a trigger event can be an insert
update or delete operation now let me
take you to mySQL workbench where we
will learn how to create triggers and
Explore More on how it works so I am on
MySQL workbench so first let me go ahead
and create my connection
I'll give my password
all right now this will take you to my
SQL editor okay so first and foremost
let me create a new database called
triggers
so I'll write my SQL command as
create
database
triggers
let me run this
okay so you can see here one row
affected I have created my database that
is triggers
next I'm going to move inside this
database so I'll write the command use
triggers
let's run this
okay
now inside this triggers database we'll
be creating our different tables so
let's check if we have any tables I'll
use the command show tables
now you see there are no tables in this
database
all right
first let's see how before insert
trigger works
so for before insert trigger we'll
create a table called customers and
verify the age of each customer
so I'll give a comment before
insert
trigger
so let me go ahead and create my
customers table I'll write create table
customers
and I'll give my column names as
cast underscore ID which is customer ID
this is going to be an integer
then we have the age of the customer
this is again an integer
and we'll have the
name of the customer
the name of the customer will be a varka
type I'll give the size as 30
all right
let's create this table okay so we have
successfully created our customers table
now moving ahead I am going to write my
before insert trigger command so we'll
start with a delimiter
so a delimited is a marker for the end
of each command
next
I'll write my create trigger
followed by the trigger name
I'll give a valid trigger name such as
each underscore verify
I'll write
before trigger
it should be before insert
on
my table name would be
customers
then I'll write for
each row
if
Nu dot each
is less than zero
then
set
new DOT each
equal to 0 which means
while inserting your values to the each
column in case the age value is negative
we'll convert the age to zero
I'll give a semicolon
and then I'll write end if
I'll give another semicolon
and
close the delimiter
now let me run this
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let's insert a few values
onto customers
so I'll write insert into customers
values
101 which is the customer ID I'll give
the age as 27 and let's say the name of
the customer is
James
let's insert another record
give the value as 1 0 2 and this time
I'm purposely giving the age as minus 40
Which is less than 0 so that you can see
the output clearly
I have given the customer name as Amy
let's insert two more records the
customer ID with 103 has an ease of 32
and let's see the name is Ben
I'll give another comma
and finally we'll insert our fourth
customer record
the customer ID is 104
the age I am giving as minus 39 Which is
less than 0 again and let's say
the customer name is Angela
all right
now let me run this
okay so we have successfully inserted
four rows of information to our
customers table
now let's see the difference since we
had created a
age verified trigger
which would
change the values of the each column in
case the each value is less than zero so
now that we have inserted four records
to a customer
so
let's see what we have in the customers
table
now let me run it
there you go so if you see this
for those customers where the age was
less than 0 such as 1 0 2 and 1 0 3 you
can see here
our trigger has automatically converted
those values to zero
if you can see the trigger we had
created we had set a new age to zero if
the age was less than 0.
and this is the output we get
so here we looked at how a before insert
trigger works all right now moving ahead
let's understand how an after insert
trigger works so I'll give a
comment here
as after insert
trigger
now in this example we'll create two
tables customers and message
now the trigger will be fired if the
birthday column has a null value in the
customer's table you will get a message
to update your date of birth
okay
so first let me create
my customers table
now since we already have one customer
stable I'll name it as customers 1.
and
let me give the column names
so the First Column would be the ID
column this is going to be an integer
and I'll use the auto increment
parameter
and this will be my primary key as well
next we'll have the name of the customer
this is going to be of type War car
and I'll use
not null constraint
next
we'll have the email ID of the customer
this is again going to be of varka type
and
the column we are interested in is the
birthday column
so I'll write birth date
this is going to be of type date
okay
so let's create our table
all right now we'll create our second
table
which is going to be
message
let's create the columns this will have
ID int and
I'll use the
Auto increment operator
next we'll have the
message ID
this is going to be of integer type
will
have a column called message
this will be a worker type let's say 300
characters
and not null
and I'm going to set
my primary keys
as ID and
message ID
let's create our second table then
so we have some error here let's debug
the error
okay so I forgot to close the bracket
here all right now let me
run this table all right so we have
created our message table as well
next
I'll write my after insert trigger
command so I'll write
delimiter
next I'll use
create trigger command so I'll write
create
trigger
my trigger name would be check
underscore null underscore date of birth
after
insert
on
customers
one
for
each row
begin
if
new DOT
birth date
is
null
then
we are going to insert
into our message table
we'll give the columns as
message ID and
message
values
new DOT ID comma I'm going to use the
concat function
where I'll
give my
message let's say hi
followed by the name
followed by
let's say please
update your
date of
birth
okay
now I'll write end if
I'll
close the delimiter
okay
so let me go to the top and recheck
if you have created our trigger
correctly so I have my trigger name
after insert on customers 1 for each row
begin if our new birthday has a null
value then we'll pass in a message
saying hi
the name of the customer
then the message would be please update
your date of birth
all right so let's run the trigger okay
now
the next step is to
insert a few records to customer table
so my name of the table is customers one
okay
I'll give the column names as name
email
and birth
okay
will
pass in a few values
so our first customer's name let's say
is Nancy
comma
I'll give my
email ID let's say Nancy at the rate
abc.com
now
let's see I'm purposely passing the date
of birth as null
I'll give a comma
my next customer let's say the name of
the customer is Ronald
and then I'll give the
email ID
such as Ronald at the rate
xyz.com
and this time I'm going to pass in the
date of birth let's say 1998
November
and let's say 16th
okay
now we'll
add another customer let's say Krish
will give the email ID of Chris
so Krish at the rate xyz.com
and let's see
we'll give the date of birth as 1997.
08 20.
and finally We'll add
one more record for another customer
let's say Alice
I'll give the email ID as Alice
at the rate abc.com
and this time I'll purposely pass
the date of birth as null
all right
so let's run the insert query okay
now
let me display the message table for you
so that you can
see the output
and how our
after insert trigger works
there you go so if you see this we had
inserted four rows of information out of
which the first customer ID and
the fourth ID had null data birth so for
those two values you have the messages
hi Nancy please update your date of
birth and then you have high Alice
please update your data both now you can
give a space between High and
the name of the customer
all right now moving ahead let's
understand how before update trigger
works so I'll give a comment here as
before update
okay
now
to show you how before update works
first we'll create
a table called employees
all right so let me create my table that
is create table
employees
I'll give my column as
employee ID
this is going to be an integer type
and
it will be my primary key
next we'll have the employee name
this will be of
varka type
and let's say the size would be 25
comma then we'll have the age of the
employee age will be of integer type
and finally we'll have the salary of the
employee salary will be of type float
let's create this table
all right now the next step is to insert
a few records to
our employees table okay so here on the
notepad I have already
written my insert query so I have
inserted nearly seven records so let me
paste it here all right
I'll just go ahead and run this insert
query so that will insert
seven employees to our table
okay
next
we'll write our before update trigger
command
so first and foremost I'll write my
delimiter
followed by the create trigger command
I'll give my
trigger name as update underscore
trigger
let's bring this to the top
okay
I'll use
before update
on
my table that is employees
for
each
row
I'll write begin
my condition would be if
new DOT
salary
is equal to let's say
ten thousand dollars
I'll write then
set
new DOT salary
equal to 85 000 dollars
I'll give a semicolon
then I'll use
else if
new DOT salary
is less than
ten thousand dollars then
I'll set
new DOT salary
to let's say
seventy two thousand dollars
I'll give a semicolon
I'll end the if statement
I'll close the delimiter
by giving a semicolon
okay
so
if you see the employees table we have
the salary values here
now in case
while updating the table
if the salary is equal to ten thousand
dollars we'll set the new salary to
eighty five thousand dollars
else if the salary is less than ten
thousand dollars we'll set the salary
column values to seven to two thousand
dollars
so let's go ahead and run this
trigger query
all right
now let me use my
update command so I'll write update
employees
I'll write set
salary is equal to let's say eight
thousand dollars now if you see our
trigger query we are setting the salary
to eight thousand dollars which is
clearly less than
ten thousand dollars so our new salary
would be seven to two thousand dollars
so let me run this okay
so you can see here six rows affected
so I'll write now select star from
employees
let's run this
okay if you see this
we have converted our salary column to
seventy two thousand dollars since we
updated the salary to eight thousand
dollars and according to our trigger
query if it's less than ten thousand
dollars the salary should be seven to
two thousand dollars which you can see
here
all right now moving to our final demo
this time we are going to explore how
before delete trigger command works
so in this example we'll create a table
called salary
we'll store the deleted record in a new
table using the before delete trigger
so first
I'll give my comment as
before trigger
comments are always useful
since they make your query more readable
so let me now create my salary table so
I'll write create
table
salary
I'll give my
column names as Eid which is employee ID
and I'll set it as primary key
comma
I'll give another column let's say valid
from
which means the date from which this
salary was effective
is going to be of type date and not null
and then I'll have the amount
will be of type float
and again not null constraint
let me run the create table
command okay so we have created our
salary table now the next thing is to
insert a few values
so I'll write insert into salary
I'll give my column names as Eid comma
valid from
comma amount
I'll write values
my first employee ID would be one zero
one
followed by a date let's say 2005
May
and
0 1 which is first of May 2005.
let's say the amount is fifty five
thousand dollars
I'll give another row of information
this time the employee ID is 102
and
I'll give a valid from date
let's say the amount is 68 000.
I'll give
another employee ID let's say one zero
three
2006.
and let's say the amount is 75 000
dollars
okay
let's run this
all right
you can verify also so I'll write select
star from salary
you can see here we have inserted three
rows of information
all right
the next step is to create
another table that will store the
deleted rows so I'll write create
table
let's say the name of the table is
create
or let's say salary delete
I'll write salary Del
now this will have the IDE
the type would be integer and primary
key
I'll also use the auto increment
operator
next we have the Eid which is of type
integer
I'll write valid from
date and not null
then I have the amount column which is
of type float and not null
foreign
column would be deleted
at
the data type will be time stamp
I'll use the default constraint as now
so this will return the time and the
date at which the record was deleted
all right
let me create this table okay
finally
let me write my before delete trigger
command so I'll first declare my
delimiter
let's say this time I'm using the dollar
symbol
I'll write create
trigger
my trigger name would be
salary underscore delete
before
delete
on my table that is salary
for
each row
I'll write begin
next
let's insert
into
salary
delete
I'll give my columns as employee ID
valued from
an amount
now we'll insert a few values
I'll write values
pulled Dot
Eid comma
Old Dot
valid from
comma Old Dot amount
I am going to
close
with the delimiters
all right
so let's run our
before delete trigger all right now let
me go ahead and delete one of the
records from the salary table so I'll
write delete from salary where
employee ID is let's say 103.
let me run this query
okay so you have successfully deleted
one of the
records in the table
now if you see
our other table that is salary delete
you will find
this information present in the salary
delete column so we have deleted one row
of information that is for employee
id103 which you can find it here now
the final column that is delete at shows
the time at which the information was
deleted or the row was deleted
all right so let me go to the top and
just
give you a recap of what we did in this
demo so first we created our database
called triggers
then
we started with before insert trigger
where we inserted customer table and
then
we verified the age of the customers
so we saw if the age was less than zero
then we set these to zero
we inserted a few records to the
customers table and purposely we
inserted some negative
age records and then we converted this
either cost to zero
then we learned how an after insert
trigger works so we created two tables
customers one and message
so wherever
the customers date of birth was missing
we passed in a message saying hi the
name of the customer please update your
date of birth
all right
now moving ahead
we saw how before update trigger works
and finally we learned about
before delete trigger
and to get ahead with this successful
career simply learn offers post graduate
program in full stack web development
with this amazing program you will be
benefited with Caltech ctme postgraduate
certificate receive up to 25 CEUs and
caltex ctme attend master classes from
Caltech ctma instructors live virtual
classes led by industry experts Hands-On
projects and integrated Labs by the end
of this course you will be skilled with
agile Java hibernet and jpa spring core
50 HTML5 and css3 AWS JavaScript and
there is used list on the board
expertise and tools like angular css3
Docker git HTML5 Jenkins mongodb and
MySQL will add value to your resume so
hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box so in this video we
will learn some queries in SQL we'll
also have a look at stored procedures
and learn about triggers in SQL we'll
cover views in SQL and look at some of
the important Windows functions in SQL
now to learn all of these we'll be using
the MySQL workbench on Windows
so let's get started with sub queries in
SQL
so let me head over to my MySQL
workbench
So currently I am on my MySQL workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so I'll give my password
I'll click on OK
all right so this is my my SQL workbench
query editor so first we are going to
learn sub queries let me give a comment
and write sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
sub query is so a sub query is a query
within another SQL query that is
embedded within the where Clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that I'll
be using my
database that is SQL underscore intro so
I'll write my command use SQL underscore
intro
now this database has a lot of tables
I'll be using the employee stable that
is present inside SQL underscore intro
Let me just expand this and you can see
here we have an employee stable
so let me first show you the contents
within this table I'll write select star
from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee ID employee name each gender
there's date of joint Department City
and salary and we have information for
20 employees if I scroll down you can
see there are 20 employees present in
our table
so let's say you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
the average salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query so let me show you how to write a
sub query
I'll write the select statement
in the select statement I'll pass
by column names that I want to display
so the column names I want are the
employee name
that I want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next I'll use a where condition where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees so
I'll write salary greater than
after this I am going to write my sub
query
so I'll give select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees
and I'll close the bracket and give a
semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once you get the average salary number
we'll use this where condition where
salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if I run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is 75 350 dollars
now I want to display all the employees
who have salary greater than 75
350 dollars so let's run our sub query
there you go so there are eight
employees in our table who have a salary
greater than the average salary of all
the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary
so if we have one employee whose name is
John
let me
run the table once again
okay if I scroll down
you see we have an employee
as John
you see this
our employee ID 116 is John and his
salary is sixty seven thousand dollars I
want to display all the employees whose
salary is greater than John's salary so
basically all the employees who are
earning more than 65 000 I want to print
them
so let's see how to do it I'll write
select
I want the employee name comma the
gender of the employee
I also want the department and salary
from my table name that is employees
I'll write where
salary is greater than
I'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket I'm
going to give my inner query that is
Select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is John
So within single quotations I'll give
John as my employee
I'll end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
John has which is sixty seven thousand
dollars now I want the employees who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see
12 rows returned which means there are
12 employees in our table who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars you see here all these employees
have a salary greater than sixty seven
thousand dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic Model so I'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website I'll just show you the
website so this is the website that is
MySQL tutorial.org
you can see here they have very nice
articles blogs from where you can learn
MySQL in detail so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website you see here
they have a MySQL sample database if you
click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
MySQL sample database
and the name of the database is classic
models all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session if I expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have qriket
customers as employees
office this orders order lines and many
more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table first let me show you the
content that is present inside
the products table first
if I run this
you see here it says 110 rows return
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock Buy price
MSRP
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the details of
all the orders
let me show you
the records
or the details tables has okay so there
are thousand records present in this
table you have the order number the
product code quantity ordered price of
each item you have the order line number
as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products whose price of each product is
less than hundred dollars for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables and we are going to
write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here in the order details
table we have a column called price each
I want to display the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way I'm going to do is
I'll write select
product code comma
product name now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is production order details
here you can see this is the product
code column
comma MSRP which is present inside the
product stable again
from my table that is
products
where
I'll write
product
code
I'm going to use the in operator
next I'll write my inner query that is
Select
product code
from my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than 100 dollars
let me run this
okay so you can see there are total 83
products in our table which have
a price less than hundred dollars you
can see the
price here
okay
now we learn another Advanced Concept in
SQL which is known as stored procedures
I'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an SQL code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again save it as a stored procedure
and then call it to execute it
so in this example I want to create a
stored procedure that will return the
list of players who have scored more
than six goals in a tournament
so I have a database called SQL
underscore IQ
these are a few databases that I've
already created so this database has a
table called players if I expand the
tables
option you see we have a table called
players and you can see the columns
player ID the name of the player the
country to which the player belongs to
and the number of goals each player has
scored in a particular tournament
so I'll write a stored procedure that
will return the list of top players who
have scored more than 6 goals in a
tournament
so first of all let me Begin by
using MySQL underscore IQ database
we'll run it
so now we are inside the SQL underscore
IQ database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are six players in our
table
we have the player ID
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so I'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this it should start with
a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter I'll write
ambers and ampersand
next I'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name
let's say amount to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin I'll write my select
statement
I want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from my table that is
players
where
I'll write goals is greater than
6.
you give us semicolon
then
I'll end my
procedure with a delimiter that was
double ambison
next
I'll write
delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space okay
now let's run our stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our store procedure now the way
to run a stored procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals are not
goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll edit here as well
now let's create it again
okay
now to
call my procedure I'll write call space
followed by the procedure name which is
top underscore players
if I run this you can see
we have two players in our table who
have scored more than six goals so we
consider them as the top players in a
particular tournament
all right
now there are other methods that you can
use while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so I'll give a comment
stored procedure using in parameter
all right
so for this example I'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees based on their
salaries
so if you have a table
in our SQL underscore IQ database which
is called employee details
I'm going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of joint City
and salary
using this table I'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and we'll use the in parameter so let me
show you how to do it
I'll write
delimiter
this time I am going to use
forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
for stored procedure
sort by
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure I'll give my
parameter in
I'll create a variable bar and assign a
data type integer
then I'll write begin
followed by my select statement where
I'll select the name
each
salary
from
my table name that is
EMP details or employee details
I am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
I want to display
limited number of
records so I'm using this
limit keyword and my variable VAR which
I
created here
I learned my select statement
I'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and I'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not here
you have an option to see the stored
procedures let me just refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our stored procedure I'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by salary
and inside this I'll give my parameter
which was actually VAR and this VAR
we have used in limit
let's say I want to display only the top
three records of the employees who have
the top three highest salaries
okay so let me run it
there you go so Amy Sarah and Jimmy but
the top three employees who have the
highest salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement and we
called our stored procedure and passed
in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select statement inside
stored procedure you can also use other
statements let's say update
so I'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of Select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the in
operator twice
so let me show you how to do it
I'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be forward slash
then I'll write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the
update salary name
I'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
I'll assign is worker 20
I'll again use my in parameter I'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
I'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement I'll write
update
table name that is employee details set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and I'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure if I refresh this
you can see I have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's see
first of all I'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table okay
so we have six rows of information let's
say you want to update the salary of
employee Jimmy or let's say
Mary
from seventy thousand to let's say
seventy two thousand
or let's say eighty thousand
so I'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time I'm going to pass in two
parameters the first parameter will be
the employee name and next with a comma
I'll give my new salary that I want to
so my employee name let's say is Mary
and the salary I want
to be updated is let's say eighty
thousand dollars
I'll give a semicolon
and I'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go if you see this record
for Mary we have successfully updated
the salary to eighty thousand dollars
now moving ahead
we learned to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter so I'll give a
comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
will create total employees as an output
parameter and the data type would be an
integer
the count of the female employees is
assigned to the output variable which is
total underscore emps using the into
keyword let me show you how to write a
stored procedure using the out parameter
so first I'll declare my delimiter
to forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be SP underscore
count
employees
and inside this I am going to give my
out parameter and the variable name that
is total underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next I am going to write begin
followed by my select statement that is
Select I want the
count of total employees
and the output I am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is EMP underscore
details
where
sex is equal to
F which means female
I'll go by semicolon
next I'll end it
with the DB limiter and I am going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is
colon
so let me tell you what I am doing here
I am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure I am going
to count the total number of female
employers that are present in our table
EMP underscore details so I've used my
out parameter and I'm creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer here in the
select statement I am counting the names
of the employees and the result I am
storing it in total underscore emps
I have used my wear condition where the
gender of the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure
let's refresh this
okay you can see we have a new stored
procedure SP underscore count employees
now
to call it I'll write call
the name of the procedure that is Count
underscore SP underscore count
employees
within brackets I'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
F underscore EMP
will give a semicolon then I'll write
select
at the rate F underscore
EMP as female employees
okay
so as is an alias name let's run this
one by one first I'll call my procedure
and then we'll display the total number
of female employees you can see in our
table we have three female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next Topic in this
tutorial on Advanced SQL now we are
going to learn about triggers in SQL
so I'll give a
comment here
reverse in SQL
so first let's understand what is a
trigger so a trigger is a special type
of stored procedure that runs
automatically when an event occurs in
the database server there are mainly
three types of triggers in SQL we have
the data manipulation trigger we have
the data definition trigger and login
triggers
in this example we'll learn how to use a
before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the student's rule
number the age the name and the students
marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than 0
so in case the marks are less than 0 a
trigger will automatically set the marks
to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our table
that is
students
all right
so I'll write
create
table
student
now this table will have the student
roll number
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or bearing character
size I'm giving it as 30 finally we have
the marks as floating type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table
now
I'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time I'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is Mark
underscore
let's say verify
I am going to use a before insert
trigger so I'll write before insert
on my table name that is student
next I'll write for each row
if
new DOT marks
is less than 0
then
will set
new DOT
marks equal to 50.
so this is my
condition first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0 we'll assign a value
50 to that student because usually the
marks are not less than 0 in any exam
I'll write end if
semicolon and I'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command I'll run it
it says triggle already exists so in
this case we need to update the
trigger name let's say
I'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for St
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is Mark and
not marks so here we need to change it
as Mark instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so I'll write insert into student
I'll write
values
and give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10
the name is it's a Ruth
and the marks is let's say 75 point
zero
if a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student rule number is 502
age is 12
the name is let's say Mike
and this time I'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the Third
record
for student rule number 503
ages 13
the name is Dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by div is
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
these is 10
knee while enter as Jacobs
and this time again I'm purposely giving
the marks in negative
12 point let's say 5.
close the bracket and give a semicolon
and I'll run my insert statement okay so
we have inserted four rows of
information to our student table
now
let me run the select query I'll write
select star from student
if I run this you see the difference
there you go
so originally we had inserted
for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504 for Jacobs the marks
was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because when we
created our trigger we had set our marks
to 50 in case the marks were less than
zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name in this case our
trigger name is
St
I'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
you give this as a comment
okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial Concept in SQL which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
I'll give a comment as views in SQL
okay
now
to learn views I am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as I mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use classic models so I'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so I'll write select
star from customers
okay
I missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name customer number we
have the address State country and other
information
now I'll write a basic view command
using this customer table the way to
write is I'll write create
View
followed by The View name which is cast
underscore details
then you write as
select
I am going to select a few column names
from my original customer table which is
this one so I need the customer name
let's say I need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number and the City
all right
I'll write from my table that is
customers
if I run this
my view that is cast details will be
created
let's run it there's some error here
because the name of the table is
customers and not customer
I'll give an S and I'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and to display the contents that are
present inside our view I can write
select star from followed by The View
name that is custom details
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name the phone number and the City of
the different customers that we have in
our table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that I am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table I am talking about the products
table and the product lines table
present inside classic models database
so before I start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description and there's some HTML
description and image
so
I'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing create
View
followed by The View name that is
product underscore
description
as I'll write
select
product
name
comma
then I'll write
quantity
in stock
I also want the MSRP
now these three columns are present
inside the products table and next from
the
product lines table I want the text
description
of the products
so I'll write from
products table
I'll give an alias as p
followed by Inner join my other table
that is
product lines as let's say PL
on
the common column that is product line
so P Dot
product line
is equal to
I'll give a space
PL Dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables and our view name is product
underscore description let us run it all
right so we have our view ready
now let me
view or display what is present inside
our product underscore description
View
I'll add select start from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock msrpn textual
descriptions of the different products
in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view instead of product
underscore description you want to give
some other name so I'll just give a
comment rename description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement I'll write rename table
product
underscore description Which is my
old name
I want to change this name to let's say
I'll give vehicle description
since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so I'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see I have
renamed my
View
so here if I just refresh it
and I'll expand this you can see we have
the cash details view and we have the
vehicle underscore description View
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
I'll write display views
just a comment
now to show all the views you can use so
full tables
where
table
underscore
type is equal to within single quote
I'll write View
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error
this should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so I'll write drop
view followed by The View name let's say
I want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view
I'll write drop View cast underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cast underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about Windows functions
now Windows functions were Incorporated
in MySQL in the 8.0 version
so Windows function in MySQL are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my SQL underscore intro
database
so we'll find the total combined salary
of the employees for each department
so first let me switch my database to
SQL underscore
into database
I'll run it okay
I'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we'll partition our table by department
and print the total salary and this we
are going to do using
some windows functions in MySQL
so I'll write
select
I want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next I'll write
the sum of salary
over
I want to partition it by
Department
so I'll write Partition by Department
which is Dept
and I'll give an alias as
total salary so that it will create a
new column with the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go so here we have created
another column in our result that is
total salary and for each of the
employees and the respective departments
you have the highest salary so in
finance the highest salary of one of the
employees was
155 000 dollars
similarly if I come down we have the
highest salary from HR if I scroll
further we have the highest salary from
ite marketing product sales and the tech
team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function I'll write
select
a row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so I'll write order by salary
I'll give the
Alias as row num
we give a comma
and I want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees
and I'll order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a row num column and we
have successfully given row numbers to
each of the records you can see it
starts from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first I'll create a table
I'll write create table
let's say I'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's see we have in this table the
student ID which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type worker
the size is 20
I'll create the small table with a few
records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so I'll write insert
into
demo
values
I'll give 101
the name is
Shane
give a comma
I'll insert the second student name 102
the name is Bradley
give a comma
this time
for 1 0 3 we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
hereth
give a comma I'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated one zero three
next we have one zero four
the name of the student let's say is
Nathan
then again let's see for
the fifth student which is Kevin we have
two records
I'll copy this
and I'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you I'll write select
star from demo
if you see this we have a few
information that are duplicated in our
table
that is for student id103 and student ID
105.
now I am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table I'll write
select student underscore ID comma
student underscore name
I'll give another comma and write
row underscore number
within brackets
I'll write partition
by
St underscore ID
comma
St underscore name
okay
then I'll write
order by St underscore ID
close the bracket I'll give an alias as
ronum
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right if you see here the richest
one student in the name Shane we have
one student in the name Bradley
but here if you see for here
the second record it says to which means
there are two records for hirath and if
I scroll down there is one record for
Nathan and there are two records for
Kevin which means Kevin is also repeated
okay
now we are going to see another Windows
function that is called rank function
in MySQL so the rank function assigns a
rank to a particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
rank values when two or more rows have
the same rank so first of all let me
create a table
and the name of the table would be a
random name we'll give it as let's say
demo one
and it will have only one
column let's say variable a of type
integer
we'll create this table first okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table which is demo one so I'll write
value
let's say 1 0 3 is repeated
I'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
we have one zero four
one zero five
we have one zero six
and let's say 106 is also repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay
let me insert these values to my table
that is demo one okay this is done
now
if I write
select
VAR underscore a
and use my rank function I'll write rank
over
then I'll
order by my variable that is VAR
underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo one
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if I run this there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test tank is 2 but
for this value which is 1 0 3 the test
rank is repeated because there was a
repetition for one zero three
so we have skipped the rank 4 here for
104 the rank is 5 now for one zero five
the rank is six now
one zero six again since the record was
repeated twice we have skipped the
eighth Rank and
our rank function has signed the same
value which is 7 for 106 and for the
last value 107 the rank is nine
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final Windows function which is
called first value
so first value is another important
function in MySQL so this function
Returns the value of the specified
expression with respect to the first row
in the window frame
all right
so what I am going to do is
I am going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and I'll write
first underscore
value which is my function and pass in
my employee name
and then I'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
I'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is employees
so let me run this and see how the
first
underscore value function works all
right so in our table
Joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
I'll write select EMP underscore name
comma
I want the department
and the salary
comma I'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
I'll write
over
here I am going to use partition
I am going to partition it by
department since I want to know the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department
and I am going to order by
salary
descending
and I'll give my Alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's run this and see the difference
in the output okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for finance Jack
had the highest salary from HR it was
Marcus similarly in it it was William
if I scroll down for marketing it was
John for product it was Alice who had
the highest salary similarly in sales we
had Joseph
and in Tech we had Angela
so this is how you can use the first
underscore value function using
partition
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on our tutorial
so let me just scroll through and show
you what we did from the beginning first
we learned about sub queries in SQL so
we initially wrote a simple sub query
and then we used our classic models
database which was downloaded from the
internet and also shown you the link
from where you can download this
database here we used two different
tables and we performed a sub query
operation
we learned how to create stored
procedures
so we learned how you can use the in
operator or the in parameter as well as
the out parameter installed procedure
after stored procedure we learned
another crucial Concept in SQL which is
called triggers now triggers are also
special kind of stored procedures so we
saw how to write a before insert trigger
you can see it here
next
we learned how to delete a trigger we
also saw how to work with views in SQL
so views are basically virtual tables
that you can create from existing tables
we also saw how you can use views using
two different tables and an inner join
and
we learned how to display views how to
rename
view names
how to delete a view and finally we
explored a few Windows function
in this tutorial we will learn how to
work with databases and tables using SQL
with python
to do this demo we'll be using our
jupyter notebook and the MySQL workbench
you can see it here
so we will write our SQL queries in the
jupyter notebook with python like syntax
if you don't have MySQL or Jupiter
notebook installed so please go ahead
and install them first
while installing the MySQL workbench you
will be asked to give the username and
password let me show you
so I am on my MySQL workbench so once
you connect it will ask for the username
and the password so I have given my
username as root and password you can
give
while installing it we'll be using the
same user ID or the username and the
password to make our connection
so let's get started with our Hands-On
demonstration part
first and foremost let me go ahead and
import the necessary libraries
I'll give a comment as import libraries
all right
so first I'll import
MySQL dot connector
next
from mysql.connector
I am going to import
my error method or the error module
next I want to import pandas as PD
so let's run this
okay there is some error here
this should be capital E and not small e
all right
you can see I have imported my important
libraries
now I'm going to create a function
that will help us create a server
connection
so I'll write my user defined function
by using the def keyword
I'll write create underscore
server underscore connection
this is going to be my
function name
and it will take in
three parameters first is the hostname
next is the username
and then we have the user password
all right
I'll give a colon
and then in the next line I am going to
Define a variable
which is going to be connection and I'll
assign it to a value called none
now we'll be using exception handling
techniques to connect to our MySQL
server
the try block lets you test a block of
code for errors and the accept block
will handle the errors
so I'll write
try and give a colon
and then
I am going to reassign the connection
variable
to a method which is
MySQL Dot
connector
dot connect
now this
mysqlconnector.connect method sets up a
connection so it establishes a session
with the MySQL server if no arguments
are passed it uses the already
configured or default values so here
we are going to pass in
three parameters the first is the
host name
I'll write host equal to
hostname which is host underscore name
I'll give a comma
then I'll write
user
equal to
user underscore name
next will be my
password
and
I'll assign the value user underscore
password
all right
now
I am going to
use a print statement and write
MySQL
database
connection
successful
after this
I'll give my except block
so I'll use the keyword accept
here I'll write error as
err
or do a colon and then I'm going to use
the print statement
here I am going to use some
print formatting techniques using the F
letter
I'll write error colon
and I'll use curly braces
give error and then I'll close the
double quotes
after this
I am going to
return
my connection
all right
let me give a comment here
we are going to assign our password
so we need to put our
MySQL
terminal password
so this password you assign it while
installing MySQL workbench
I'll write
p w
and I'll give my password which is
simply at the rate one two three four
five
and then
I'm going to give my database name so
I'll give
database name
here
I am going to write DB
equal to this is the database I want to
create which is going to be MySQL
underscore python
let me just scroll this down
okay
now I'll say
connection
equal to
I'll pass in my
user defined function name which is
create
server connection
and the parameters which are going to be
localhost that is my
hostname
my username which is root and then I'll
give PW
which is my password that is exactly
simply at the rate one two three four
five let's just run it now
okay there is an error here we need to
remove this
double quotation
all right
made another mistake here this this
should be root
okay you can see here mySQL database
connection successful
all right
next
we are now going to create a database
that is MySQL underscore python so I'll
give a comment create
MySQL underscore python database
again to create this database I am going
to create another user defined function
using the def keyword
I'll write
the function name as create database
pass in the parameters as connection
comma query
give a semicolon
and in the next line
I'll write cursor equal to
I'm going to make the connection so I'll
write connection Dot
cursor
and I'll give the parenthesis
so this mysql's cursor of MySQL
connector python is used to execute
statements to communicate with the mySQL
database the MySQL cursor class
initiates objects that can execute
operations such as the MySQL statements
okay
next
I am going to again use my try and
accept block so I'll write
try
give a colon and here I am going to use
cursor Dot
execute
within that I am going to pass in my
query
next I'll use a print statement
and the message I am going to display is
database
created successfully
after this
I am going to write my accept block
I'll write accept
error as err
give a colon and then I'll use a print
statement I'll write print
I'll use the formatting again
error
colon
and I'll write
within single course I'll give curly
braces
err and then I'll close the double
quotes
next
let's
use the variable
to create
underscore
database
underscore query
and
here I am going to write my
SQL query to create the database so I'll
write create
database
and followed by that I'll give my
database name which is going to be MySQL
underscore python
okay
after this
I'll call my function which is create
database
and I'll pass in the parameters the
first one is connection
and next
the query is create underscore database
underscore query let me just copy it
and I'm going to paste it here
all right so what I am doing here is
I am creating a new function
that is to create a new database with
the name
MySQL
underscore python which you can see it
here
now this function takes in two
parameters connection and query
I am using the connection dot cursor
function which is often used to execute
SQL statements using Python language and
then I have created my try and accept
blocks
so this try block statements will try to
create my new database which is MySQL
underscore python in case it fails to
create the new database the excerpt
block will work so here I am writing my
SQL query to create a new database which
is create database
followed by the database name and I am
assigning it to a variable which is
create database query and then I'm
calling my function create database and
passing in the two parameters connection
and the query all right so let's just
run it
all right you can see here it has
created my database successfully
now
you can verify this by checking the
MySQL workbench or the MySQL shell
you can see on the MySQL workbench here
on the left panel under schemas there is
a database called MySQL underscore
python let me just expand it now we
haven't created any table so it's not
showing it now
the next step we are going to connect to
this database
so let's go ahead and connect to our
database that we have just created I'll
write the comment as connect to
database
now to connect to a database I'm again
going to create a user defined function
using the def keyword I'll write create
underscore
DB which is for database underscore
connection
and the parameters it will take is the
host name
followed by the username
then we have the user password
and finally we have the
database name
I'll give a colon
in the next line I am going to create my
variable
which is connection and then I'll assign
it to a value
none
after this I am going to use my
exception handling techniques so I'll
write my drive block first
I am going to reassign my connection
variable
using the
MySQL connector method so I'll write
MySQL Dot
connector dot connect
so this method
will take in the
parameters
so first
it will take the
hostname
I'll write
host equal to
host underscore name
I'll give a comma next it will take the
username so user equal to user
underscore name
give another comma
next
it will take the user password
I'll use pass WD equal to
user underscore password
we'll give another comma and this time
it is going to be the database name so
I'll write database equal to DB
underscore name
now
let's use the print statement
and the message we are going to print is
MySQL
database
connection
successful
all right
finally
we'll write my
accept block I'll write accept
error as err
or give a colon and then I'll use the
print statement
f
within double quotes I'll write error
colon
within single quotes curly braces I'll
write err
and will close the double quotes
finally
this function
will return
the connection value
all right
let's run it and there you go it has run
successfully so we have connected to our
database
now it's time for us to execute SQL
queries
I'll give another comment saying
execute
SQL
queries
all right
now to execute our SQL queries I'll use
another user defined function which is
execute
underscore
query
and I'll pass in the parameters as
connection and
query
give a colon
I'm going to write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
now this is used to establish a
connection and run SQL statements
next we'll use the
try and accept block so I'll write try
cursor
Dot execute
this will take in one parameter which is
going to be my query
and then I'll write
connection
Dot commit
which is another method
now let's use the print statement
so I'll write
print
let's say the message would be query
was successful
and then
we'll write our accept block which is
accept
if the try block doesn't work through an
error
using the print statement
within double course inside the inside
the curly braces I'll write err
and close the double quotes
all right so let's run it
okay so we have successfully created our
various functions that were needed to
create a database establish a connection
and to execute our queries
all right
now it's time for us to create our first
table inside the MySQL underscore python
database
so to do that I am going to write my
create command in SQL
so first we are going to assign our SQL
command to a python variable using
triple quotes to create a multi-line
string so let me show you how to do that
I'll write my
variable name
which is going to be create
orders
table
it is always recommended to use relevant
variable names to make it more readable
and now
I am going to use triple quotes
so the triple quote
will ensure
I can create my multi-line string
inside the triple code I am going to
write my
create command which is create table
here I am going to create an order
stable first
and
inside the orders table I am going to
create my
column names the First Column would be
the order ID
it is going to be of type integer and
I'll assign this order ID as my primary
key column
we'll give a comma
next
the second column would be
customer
underscore name
the customer name column would be of
type
varying character so I'll write worker
and I'll give a size of 30. and this is
also going to be
not null
moving ahead my fourth column would be
the product name column
so I'll write product underscore name
product name will be of type
varying character the size is let's say
20 and it is also not null
next
I am going to create my
fourth column which is the date on which
the item was ordered or the product was
ordered
so I'll write date ordered
the data type will be date
next
I'll create
a quantity column to keep track of the
number of quantities that were ordered
this is of type integer
my next column would be unit price which
will basically have information about
the price of each unit of product
unit price can be of type float
and finally I'll have the
phone number of the customer
I'll write phone number phone number can
be kept as of type varying character
I have assigned a size of 20
now let's give a semicolon and
will
close the
triple quotes
all right
so this is how the syntax would look
like
next
to run this we are first going to
call our create DB function so let me
give a comment as
connect to the database
I'll write connection
equal to
create underscore DB underscore
connection
my parameters would be
my hostname which is localhost my
username which is root
comma my password
and then my database name which is
MySQL underscore python so I'll write
just DB
all right
finally let's execute this query using
the execute underscore
query function that we had created
earlier
this takes in two parameter the first
one is connection
followed by
the variable name which is create
orders underscore table
let us run it
okay there is some error here let's see
what's the error
okay so here we have put four double
quotes this should be triple quotes now
let's run it
okay there is another here let's debug
it
it says name cursor not defined
let me just roll it to the above cell if
you see here in our execute underscore
query
function instead of
cursor
I have written cursor so R is missing
let's rerun this
and now let's run this again there you
go you can see here mySQL database
connection successful even our query was
also successful
now if you want to recheck if the table
that is orders was created or not you
can check it on the MySQL workbench so
let me show you how to do it so I am on
my MySQL workbench and under MySQL
underscore python database you have
something called Stables let me just
right click and I'll select refresh all
there you go you can see this Arrow just
click on this arrow and here you can see
we have a table called orders so we have
created a table called orders now you
can check the columns as well you have
the order ID you have the order ID the
customer name product name ordered date
quantity unit price and phone number now
it's time for us to insert a few records
to this table which is orders
now to insert records I'll give a
comment as insert
data
I'll start with the
variable name let's say the variable
name is data underscore
orders
I'll give triple quotes
next
I'll write my insert into command so
I'll write insert
into
my table name that is orders followed by
values and now I'll start entering
my records for each of the rows so first
I'll give 1 0 1 which is the order ID
then I'll give the
customer's name let's say Steve
and the product he had ordered is let's
say laptop
then I'll give my date in which the item
was ordered
let's say it is 2018
I'll choose
0 6 as the month and the date is let's
say 12.
we'll give another comma this time we'll
pass in the quantity which is 2
let's say the price of each laptop was
800 dollars
and
will give a
phone number this is random let's say
six to
nine three
seven three
zero let's say
802.
all right similarly I am going to insert
five more records of different customers
and their items that they have purchased
to the stable orders so here on my
notepad I have my rest of the five
records let me just copy it and we'll
paste it in the
cell here this will save us some time
okay
let me recheck if everything is fine
I'll give a comma here all right so we
have
six customers in our table which have
their customer IDs from one zero one to
one zero six you have Steve Jaws Stacy
Nancy Maria and Danny you have the
different items they have purchased
laptop books trousers t-shirts
headphones and smart TV is the date on
which they had ordered this item the
number of quantities they had ordered
and then we have the unit price and some
random phone numbers
so let's
create the connection now I'll write
connection
equal to
I'll write create underscore DB
underscore connection
then I'm going to give my same
parameters let me just copy it from the
top which is localhost
the hostname
root is my username then we have
password and the database name
and then
I'll use the same query as above which
is execute query
I'll copy this
paste it here and instead of create
order stable variable I'll put as data
underscore orders
so this will store my
insert into command you can see the
variable I have used here is data
underscore orders
now it's time let's just run it
all right
there was some mistake here let's debug
it
again this would be triple quotes and
not
4 now let me rerun it again there you go
you can see here mySQL database
connection successful and my query was
also successful
no
we'll create
another user defined function which will
help us read query and display the
results
so I'll write
my function name as DF read underscore
query
this will take into parameters
connection and query
then I'll write cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
I'll put my
result as none
and then I'll use my try and accept
block I'll write try
cursor Dot
execute
this will take in one parameter which is
query and then I'll
give another variable which is result
equal to
cursor dot fetch all now this virtual
method
will return
all the
results in the table
I'll write return
result
next
we'll use the accept block
so I'll write accept
error as err give a colon and I'll use
my print statement
scroll this down
I'll use my formatting f
error
give a colon followed by a space
within single quotes
inside curly braces I'll give err and
close my double quotes
let's run it all right so now we are all
set
now we are going to use our select
Clause having whereby
then we'll see how to use Auto by Clause
some inbuilt functions we'll update some
records delete some records and do a lot
of other stuff
so
let's start with our first query
so our first query is going to be
using the
select statement
all right so suppose
I want to display all the records that
we have inserted into our order table
so the way to do is
I'll assign my query to a variable let's
say q1
I'll give
triple quotes
within triple quotes I'll write select
star from orders
will give a semicolon followed by the
triple quotes
now we'll establish the connection so
let me just go to the top and I'll copy
this line
which is to connect to our database
I'll paste it here
now we'll
create a variable called results that
will store the result of this query
and we are going to assign this variable
to
our function that is read query and this
read query will have
two parameters the connection and the
variable name which is q1 for the query
next to display I am going to use a for
Loop I'll write four
results
for result
in
results
print
I'll say result
now we are done
let's just run this query
there you go you can see here you have
successfully printed
all the rows in our table which is
orders you can see we have six records
in total
now we are going to explore a few more
queries so let me just copy this and we
are going to edit in the same query
I'll paste it here next let's say you
want to display individual columns from
the table and not all the columns so let
me
let me create the variable Q2
now instead of star I am going to
display only the customer name
and let's see the phone numbers of the
customer so I'll write phone underscore
number
all right the rest all Remains the Same
let me just recheck it and here instead
of
q1 will put Q2
and
let's run this cell all right you can
see here now we have displayed only two
columns the First Column is the customer
name and then we have the respective
phone numbers
okay
now let me just paste that query again
now we are going to see how you can use
an inbuilt function that is
in our table we have the
order date and from the order date we
are only going to display the different
years that are present in the order date
so to do that I am going to use the year
function I let this query instead of q1
I'll make it Q3 and here I am going to
write select
here which is my function name from my
column which is date ordered
from orders and here I'll change this to
Q3
q1 Q2 Q3 are basically query 1 query 2
and query three let's run it there you
go so we have successfully extracted the
different years present in the order
date column
now if you want to display the distinct
or the unique dates present in the
column you can
use the distinct keyword in the select
statement so the way to do it is I'll
write select
distinct
give a space
the rest of the query Remains the Same
and here the Q3 I'll write Q4
I'll make this as Q4
let's run it
you can see 2018 and 2019 are the unique
year values that are present in the
order date column
okay
now moving ahead
let's write our fifth query and this
time we are going to explore how you can
use the where clause
so I'll change this to Q5
before I write my query
so let's say you want to display all the
orders
that were ordered before
31st of December 2018.
so to filter this we are going to use
the where clause
so I'll write select
star from orders
next I'll write where
my date underscore ordered
is less than
within course I'll give my date value
which is 2018 December
31st
so all the items or the products that
were ordered before 31st of December
2018 will be displayed so let's run it
all right you can see here there are
three orders in our table which have
been ordered before
31st of December
now moving ahead
we want to display
all the orders that were made after 31st
of December
so here
what you can do is I'll just copy the
above query again I'll copy this line
so instead of less than 31st of December
2018 I'll make it as greater than so
every order that was placed after 31st
of December will be displayed
if you run it so you can see here there
are three orders in our table which were
ordered after 31st of December 2018.
now moving ahead
let's write a seventh query
now let's see how the order by Clause
Works in SQL so you can filter your
results based on a particular column or
sort it based on a particular column
so this is going to be my query seven
I'll write it from scratch again let's
see
you want to display all the columns from
the table so I'll write select star from
orders
then I am going to use order by
unit price
I'll give a semicolon
let's run this query and see the output
now if you see the result here
and you mark the unit price column
the result has been ordered in ascending
order of unit price you see here it
starts with the lowest price and then
goes on with the highest price towards
the end now if you want to order it in
descending order you can use the keyword
desc
so this will ensure your top
or the most expensive products appear at
the top and the least expensive products
appear at the bottom
all right
next
let's see how you can create a data
frame
from the given table
so as you know
using jupyter notebook and pandas you
can create data frames and work on it
very easily so with this table also we
can create our own data frame
so for that let me create an empty list
first I'll write from
DB equal to I'll assign this as an empty
list
so we are going to return a list of
lists and then create a pandas data
frame
next I'll write my for Loop I'll write
for result in
results
I'll assign result
to
list of results so I am converting the
result into a list
and then I am going to append it to the
empty variable or the empty list which
is from underscore DB Dot append
I'll append the result to
my empty list
next
we need to pass in the
columns now that will be part of our
data frame so I'll write
columns equal to this column I'll pass
it
Within a list so I'll give my first
column as order ID then we have the
customer name
next I have my
product name
then I have the date on which it was
ordered
give a comma then we'll have the
quantity column
let me write it in the next line
next we have the unit price column
and finally we have the
phone number column so I'll write within
double course
phone number
and this we are going to assign it to a
data frame so I'll be using PD Dot
data frame which is my function to
convert a list into a data frame
my variable I am going to pass is from
underscore DB
and I'll write
my next argument is columns equal to
my variable name that is columns
finally let's display
the data frame which is DF all right
so here I am creating a empty list first
and then
I am creating a
for Loop and I am appending the results
to my empty list here you can see I have
created my column list
and using pd.d to frame I'm converting
the list into a data frame
if I run this
this is append and not appends
all right you can see we have our
data frame ready this is the index
column it starts from zero onwards and
then we have the different
column names
okay
now let's see how to use the update
command
now suppose
you want to change the unit price of one
of the orders
you can use the update command so the
way to do it I'll first
create my variable let's say update
and I'll give three
quotes or triple quotes
then I'll use my update command which is
update followed by the table name that
is orders
next I'll write set
let's say unit underscore price
if you see this let's say I want to set
the unit price of trousers from 50
dollars to let's say 45 dollars I want
to update this particular record so I'm
going to write set unit price column
equal to
45 dollars where
the order ID equal to
one zero three
so this query will update the
third row in our table which is order
id103
so it will update from 50 to 45 dollars
I'll close the triple quotes
and now
I'll use the
connection
queries again
let me just paste it here
all right
I'll delete
these three lines of code and instead of
that I'll put execute underscore
query
and this will take into parameters as
always which is going to be connection
followed by the variable name that is
update
let's run it you see here it says mySQL
database connection successful where you
are successful
now you can recheck that
to do it let me just go to the top and
we'll
just copy our first query which is q1
I'll copy this
and I'll paste it here
let me just rename this now
this will be
Q8
and I'll change this as well
I'll write select start from orders
where
my order ID equal to 103.
let's see the unit price of one zero
three now you can see here instead of 50
now we have updated it to 45 dollars
all right
now the last command we are going to say
is how you can delete a record from the
table
I'll write delete command as my comment
now to delete a query
I'll first
give my variable name which is delete
underscore order
and I'll pass in within
triple quotes
next I'll write my delete query which is
delete from my table name that is orders
then I'll give my where Clause where
let's say I want to delete my order ID
105.
let me just go to the top and explain
you again
so if you see this we want to delete the
order id105 which was for customer name
Maria and shared ordered headphones we
want to completely remove this
particular record so
I have my delete query ready
now let me just
create my connection and display the
results so I'll go to the top and I'll
copy this connection command which also
has the execute query command
and I'll paste it here
and I'm going to make a change here
instead of update we'll write
delete underscore order
everything looks good let's just run it
you can see our query was successful
and now
if you want to print it let me just show
you
I'll just copy this
will paste it here
I'll make this as q9
I want to verify if my order id105 was
deleted or not
instead of this statement I'll write
select star from orders
and here I'll change this to q9
if I run this
you can see it here you can Mark order
id105 was deleted and it no more appears
in this table
all right so this brings us to the end
of the demonstration on SQL with python
let me just
scroll you through what we did so first
we imported the important libraries
MySQL connector then we imported the
error function then we imported pandas
using PD
we learned how to create a server
connection to mySQL database we created
a new database that is MySQL underscore
python and now we connected to the
database
we created a function to execute our
queries we saw how you can write a
create table command
then we inserted a few records to our
order stable
we created a read underscore query
command to read the queries and display
the results
then we started exploring our
different SQL commands one by one we saw
how to use select query then we selected
a few individual columns from our table
followed by using a
inbuilt function which was here then we
saw how to use the distant keyword
after that we used our where Clause to
filter our table based on specific
conditions
we saw how to order your results based
on a particular column
then we saw how you could convert the
table into a data frame using PD dot
dataframe function
finally we learned how to use the update
command and the delete command I and to
get ahead with this successful career
simply learn offers post graduate
program in full stack web development
with this amazing program you will be
benefited with Caltech ctme postgraduate
certificate receive up to 25 CEUs and
caltex ctme attend master classes from
caltex ctma instructors live virtual
classes led by industry experts Hands-On
projects and integrated Labs by the end
of this course you will be skilled with
agile Java hibernet and jpa spring core
50 HTML5 and css3 AWS JavaScript and
there is used list on the board
expertise in tools like angular css3
Docker git HTML5 Jenkins mongodb and
MySQL will add value to your resume so
hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box data is getting
bigger day by day and it has a
significant role in decision making for
companies now in order to handle these
huge amounts of data there is a need for
database and database Management Systems
now in order to communicate with these
databases you need a tool this is where
SQL comes into picture would you like to
Ace the most frequently Asked SQL
interview questions during your campus
placements to land in your dream company
well you are at the right place and on
that note hello everyone welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel I hope you
guys are doing well and staying safe in
this tutorial we will be taking you
through some most commonly asked SQL
interview questions in 2022 and for 2023
we'll look at some of the key things
that you need to keep in mind while
answering these interview questions the
general questions will revolve around
key Concepts like commands constraints
joins functions transactions and other
database related questions you may also
get some scenario based questions
wherein the interviewer might ask you to
write queries other than the theoretical
questions wherein the interviewer wants
to test your knowledge in depth so we'll
be going through all these
technicalities and see how to answer
these questions in your next interview
but before we begin if you're new to the
channel and haven't subscribed already
consider getting subscribed to our
Channel simply learn to stay updated
with all the latest tech content and hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further Ado let's
get started
so the first question is what is SQL and
why it is used SQL or structured query
language refers to a standard
programming language utilized to extract
organize manage and manipulate data
stored in relational databases SQL is
thereby referred to as a database
language that can execute activities on
databases that consist of tables made up
of rows and columns SQL commands are
used to process analyze and manipulate
the data that is stored in databases SQL
plays a crucial role in retrieving
relevant data from databases by
performing various operations like
insertion updation modification and
deletion
SQL can manage several data transactions
simultaneously where large volumes of
data are written concurrently so that is
SQL and why it is used
moving ahead let us now discuss our next
question which is why we need a database
as the technology kept on advancing the
file system had became difficult to
handle when the number of files
increased and the volume of data also
grew this is where database comes into
picture the system was no longer able to
store and retrieve data efficiently and
this created some some limitations and
drawbacks and that is when we needed a
new medium through databases now the
problem with traditional file systems is
we have data redundancy and
inconsistency redundancy means when the
same data is getting duplicated and
repeated in different location this
leads to excess and unwanted storage
which eventually results in
inconsistency where the data in
different files does not match with each
other data isolation data is isolated
because it is scattered in various files
in different locations and the files may
be in different formats as well at any
point writing new application programs
to retrieve the appropriate data becomes
difficult as the files are separated
from each other in different locations
limited data access file storage systems
usually do not have access for multiple
users this means multiple users at
different places cannot access the data
simultaneously it becomes difficult to
access important data if multiple users
are searching at the same time
security and integrity issues
data is of Paramount importance to
anyone and its privacy and its security
is one of the most important things we
need to consider data stored in files
can be easily accessed and tampered so
it is important to prevent access to
unauthorized users to hold the Integrity
of the stored data so in order to
eliminate all these drawbacks we use a
database which is further controlled by
a database management system
all right moving ahead the next question
is how does an SQL database works now
database store related information
across multiple tables and allows you to
query information using SQL commands but
the process it is a bit of
a hectic one and in order to understand
this in a simple way I have put a flow
diagram here where you can understand
how the flow between the user and the
SQL engine through the database server
is happening now a typical SQL database
engine includes a storage engine which
is a database server and the query
processor within the SQL engine now to
retrieve the data the query processor in
the SQL engine accepts and executes SQL
commands for the database server which
forwards to an application server now
this application server within the
database process the SQL request and
sets it to a web server where the user
can access the information via SQL
tables if the required data is found in
the tables that is present in the
database server it sends the information
back to the user in this way one can
find the the data that is needed from
the database by writing simple SQL
queries so this is how a traditional SQL
database works I hope you guys have
understood let us now move ahead and
discuss the next question which is what
are the main usages of SQL or you might
be asked what are the features of SQL or
you can or you might be asked why we use
SQL now SQL is responsible for accessing
and manipulating the data present in
databases by writing simple SQL queries
now the main function or the main usages
of SQL is it is used to execute query
against a database Now by writing a
simple query you can perform complex
operations to retrieve data from the
database you can also perform various
operations like insert update and delete
records for example if you have created
a new table you can insert records in
that now due to due to some reasons if
there is a modification or a change in
the record you can use the update
statement to modify them and finally if
you no longer want to process that data
or show the data in that table you can
use the delete command to delete that
data present in that table
and again as discussed earlier it is
used to perform complex operations on
the database like functions by joining
two or more tables and Etc
the next question is what do you
understand by tables and Fields in a
database
a table is a set of data that is
organized in a model in the columns and
rows format tables are considered as the
fundamental level to store data in a
relational database management system it
contains a header row at the top of the
table which gives the list of column
names
now the tables contain rows and columns
where the rows are known as records in
general and the columns are known as
Fields now a column is set of data
values of a particular type like numbers
or alphabets for example if you consider
the employee table here which has
employee ID employee name job department
number salary in the column names which
is basically considered as the different
fields and we also have different
records present in this table like if
you consider the employee details of
Rohan whose employee ID is 1011 who is
working as a data analyst so fields are
basically columns in a table with
specific information about the data and
a record is basically an individual
entry that exists in a table
all right the next question is explain
different types of commands in SQL now
mainly there are four types of commands
in SQL the first one is data definition
language or ddl data destination
language helps you to define the
database structure or schema
data manipulation language or DML DML
allows you to modify the database
instance by inserting modifying and
deleting its data
next we have data control language or
DCL DCL gives access to the data stored
in the database by granting and revoking
permissions to the user and finally we
have transaction control language or TCL
TCL commands deal with the transactions
within the database so these were some
of the important and mainly used SQL
commands
now moving ahead you might be asked to
explain any one of the SQL commands in
detail so I have taken other question
here which states that what are the
statements used under DML commands so
you need to prepare accordingly and
thoroughly so that interviewer want to
know whether you have the in-depth
knowledge of the SQL commands or not now
typically under DML commands we have
four statements the first one is Select
this command is used to fetch data from
a database table next we have insert
insert is is used to insert data into a
table of a database now if you have
created a database and if you want to
insert some record into it you can use
the insert statement next we have update
update command allows modifying a data
in the table now as discussed earlier if
you want to make changes in your
database you can use the update
statement which basically updates the
value in a given table and finally we
have delete this command allows deleting
specific rows from the table now if a
longer if you no longer want the data to
be present in your table in that case
you can use the delete statement now
guys we have select statement which also
comes under dql command which is data
query language but in most of the cases
we consider it under DML command as well
so you need not to worry so these are
the four statements that come under DML
commands moving ahead the next question
is what are aggregate functions in SQL
aggregate function SQL perform a
calculation on multiple values and
return a single value
now we have five different types of
aggregate functions in SQL the first one
is Count function count is used to
basically count the total number of
fields or number of data that you want
from your table next we have the average
average is used to calculate the average
of all the fields that are present in
the table
next we have minimum and maximum as the
name suggests they are used to find the
maximum and minimum value while
performing any complex or mathematical
calculations from your table and finally
we have some which is used to summarize
or calculate the whole of the values
that are present in the table so these
are some aggregate functions that are
used in SQL
the next question is what are
constraints in SQL constraints are a set
of rules imposed on tables of relational
databases constraints help in
maintaining the accuracy integrity and
reliability of a database
now we have total of six types of
constraints that are present in SQL the
first one is unique unique constraint
ensures that all the values in a column
are different
primary key primary key is a combination
of a not null and unique constraint
which basically uniquely identifies each
row in a table
next we have foreign key foreign key
uniquely identifies a row or record in
an other table
next we have default constraint default
constraint sets a default value for a
column when no value is specified so if
you're working on a database and if you
haven't assigned a value into that
record it will automatically give a
default value
next we have check constraint check
basically ensures that all the values in
a column satisfies a specific condition
and finally we have not null not null
ensures that a column cannot have a null
value so that was all about constraints
and the different types of constraints
that we use in SQL
next question is what are keys in SQL
and why do we use them SQL key is an
attribute or set of attributes which
help you to identify a unique row in a
table
SQL case are one of the most important
attributes of any relational database
because it plays important role to
establish a relationship between two or
more tables it also helps queries to
execute faster that is retrieval of the
records from the database becomes much
faster by using keys keys also said that
different constraint to uniquely
identify the tuples or rows from the
large data sets
all right now once you are as water Keys
the interviewer might ask what are
different types of keys used in SQL so
you have to be prepared for that as well
now in general we have four different
types of keys present in SQL the first
one is primary key the primary key in
SQL is a single or a group of fields or
columns that can uniquely identify a row
in a table for example employee ID or
student ID in a table is considered as a
primary key because it uniquely
identifies each and every record present
in that table next we have super key a
Super Key is a combination of all
possible attributes which can uniquely
identify rows or tuples in a table
next we have candidate key candidate key
can be defined as a set of one or more
columns that can identify or record or a
tuple uniquely in a table
foreign key a foreign key is a set of
attributes in a table that refers to the
primary key of another table so if you
want to connect another table using the
primary key of the existing table then
the key that is present in the uh new
table is considered as the foreign key
now for candidate key let's say I have
different uh you know Fields like let's
say aadhar card passport or driving
license as Fields present in my table so
which can uniquely identify or record
uniquely similar to that of primary key
now since candidate key is a set of one
or more columns we consider all these
all of them as candidate keys so I hope
you've understood till now uh what are
the different types of keys used in SQL
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
are some common Clauses used with select
query in SQL now as we know SQL being a
query language requires a method to
apply constraints on the data and for
that we use Clauses skill Clauses are
basically inbuilt SQL functions which
allows us to apply certain restrictions
on the data in a resultant set now with
the help of SQL Clauses we can filter
the data according to our requirement
and it also reduces the complexity of a
query which helps in writing
user-friendly queries which are easy to
read and understand as well which also
ultimately allows us to restrict the
number of outputs or the certain amount
of data that we want in our resultant
set now let us now discuss some of the
different types of Clauses used in SQL
first we have where plus it is used to
filter records in the database now as
you all know familiar that we have like
thousands and thousands of Records in
our you know database so if you want to
filter only a particular records as per
your requirement then you can give a
condition which can be done by using a
where Clause next we have ordered by
order by Source the data either in
ascending or descending order next we
have group by Group by is used to group
entries with identical data and can be
used with aggregation functions or
methods to obtain summarized database
results next we have having Clause
having Clause basically filters the rows
where aggregate values may be specified
conditions now group I and having are
almost similar to each other so you can
consider both of them to filter the
records as per your requirement next we
have the limit and again as the name
suggests it is used to restrict the
number of results from the query or the
result in the resultant set for example
if you have hundreds hundred records in
your database and if you want only 50
requests to display in a resultant set
then in that case you can use them and
finally we have the distinct clause
which is used to you know discard the
rows having any duplicate values which
basically eliminates you know certain
records that have any duplicate value so
if there are any records that are
repeated in your table then you can
eliminate them by using resting plus so
those are some of the common Clauses
that we use with select query
all right let us now discuss the next
question which is what is the difference
between care and wire care data types
now I know you've all used both these
you know data types extensively while
working on your database but due to how
frequently we use them many of us fail
to recognize their differences when
asked to choose between worker and Care
in your interview questions now the
difference is important to know from
both an interview point of view and from
the standpoint of the database design as
well when you're working on your you
know database application because uh a
poor choice of data type from both these
uh you know data types restricts the
type of data you can add which can
ultimately waste space and slow down
your query as well so it is important
that we understand the difference now
first difference between them is care is
a fixed length character string data
type and wirecare is a variable in
character string data type
and coming to care this data type can be
a single byte or a multiple byte whereas
wire care can accept character strings
up to only 255 bytes now character or
care data type can be used when the
character length is known so if you're
working or if you are specifying a
column data type wherein you know the
length of the character in such case you
can use the cat whereas on the other
side wire car is a data type which is
used when the character length is not
clear so for a string values when the
total number of character length is not
known in such case you have to take VAR
Care Now care is used when the character
length of the data is the same whereas
worker is used when the character length
of the data is changing that is when it
is variable and finally car is a static
data type and badcad is a dynamic data
type so these are some of the main and
important difference between carrot and
wire care data types and choosing
between them uh is important that
because you know it can ultimately
affect your database performance so it
is important to choose the right data
type
all right moving ahead the next question
is name few data types used in SQL I
hope you've come across this word data
type in almost every programming
languages so similar to those uh data
types present in unlike any other
programming languages we do have certain
data types which are similar in SQL as
well now as we know a data tape a
database table must have a name and data
type for each column so when building a
table an SQL Developer must decide what
kind of data will be stored in each
column so the data specifies how SQL
interact with the store data and serves
as a guide for SQL engine and
determining what kind of data is
expected inside of each column so we
have different data types like numeric
data type which has uh in type bit float
and Boolean types of uh you know
elements of data types next we have
string data type which contains care
worker and Text data types and next we
also have date time data types which
takes a different elements again which
has date format which only takes the
entry of date in year month rate we also
have date time we also have timestamp as
well now other than this we have some
miscellaneous and extra data types also
for example XML and Json formats in
order to store the data in our tables as
well so these are some of the important
data types used in SQL I hope you guys
have understood
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is
explain the difference between Group by
and order by now both these Clauses are
one of the important Clauses in SQL as
they are used to filter and sort the
data as per our requirement so it is
also again important that how we use
them and how their uh you know
specifically being used is important so
you have to understand the differences
and when to use and when not to use now
coming to group by Group by is used to
group the rows that have the same value
whereas order by is used to arrange the
data obtained as a result of a query in
a sorted form so let's say if you want
to arrange the first 10 records in
ascending order then you can use the
order byte Clause whereas if you are
let's say uh want to group certain
columns in a particular order so then in
that in that case you can use Group by
function Group by Clause now group I
always is used before the order by
clause in the select statement whereas
order by is used after the group by
clause in a select state me
so if you want to use a group by you
need to use before the order by and
similarly for uh order by also it is you
always used after the group by next
Group by uh attributes under aggregation
function cannot be in group by Clause
whereas attributes under aggregate
functions can be in order by Clause now
it is also mandatory to use aggregate
functions in the group by so whenever
you are performing function aggregate
functions like count sum average minimum
and maximum in such case you need Group
by whereas aggregate function is not
compulsory as such to use in order by
function and finally the important thing
Group by controls the presentation of
rows or tuples whereas order by controls
the presentation of columns
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is why
do we use case statement in SQL
so the case statement in SQL is a way of
handling the if else statement that we
use uh in other programming languages
which basically uh returns a value for
the condition specified now it tests a
list of conditions and returns one of
the multiple possible results so it is
used to fetch us a particular value
based on a certain condition in your
database so the case expression
basically goes through conditions and
return of value then the first condition
is met just like an if then else
statement so once a condition is true it
will stop reading and return the result
if no conditions are true it Returns the
value in the else clause and if there is
no else part and no conditions are true
it will basically return a null value so
that is what an SQL case statement does
in your SQL database so for example if
you consider an example here we have a
query such as select employee ID job
title salary and we have to mention the
keyword case and it is always followed
with a when and then keyword so I am
specifying a condition here when salary
is greater than or equals to 50 000 I
want to display a string value that is
the salary is greater than 50 000 and if
salary is equals to 50 000 I want to
display a you know message as the salary
is 50 000 and if both these conditions
are not satisfying then it will go to
the else part which will basically
return the salary is under 50 000 and it
will always end with an end as statement
so this is what case statement is in SQL
and why do we use it
all right moving ahead one of the most
important questions which is what are
joints in a SQL and explain different
types of joints
now you might have come across the SQL
joins key Awards in most of the cases
guys uh they're one of the important
statements in SQL which allows you to
access information from two or more
tables at once which also keep our
database normalized basically
normalization is allows us to keep data
redundancy low so that we can decrease
the amount of data anomalies in our
application when we delete or update a
record we'll get into that when we talk
about normalization in detail so you
just ask to understand that the joint
laws allows us to retrieve data from two
or more related tables into a meaningful
resultant set
so for example we'll understand with an
example consider a Mercedes bench which
is one of the uh you know largest
automobile manufacturing companies in
the world so let's say they're trying to
access some information of their
customers now in the database let us
assume that they have three different
tables of customer an order table and a
vehicle table now let's say they're
trying to find a particular model type
you know which a customer has purchased
in a recent time so for that in order to
find that data we have to go through
three different stages that is first
they have to find the customer table and
then they have to go to order table to
find the order ID so that they can get
into the vehicle ID details and finally
they'll fetch the model type or let's
say the the variant from the vehicle
orders now instead of that I'll just
simply join the two tables that is the
customer table and vehicle table based
on the common column that is present in
this both table which is customer ID so
with the help of this common field I can
retrieve the model and the variant
instead of searching the three tables
you know one at a time so simultaneously
I'm able to retrieve data by using
common columns in both the table so that
is one of the most important USB or the
uh factor that a joint does when you're
trying to retrieve data from more than
one table
so I hope you've understood what what
joints are and let us now understand the
different types of joints now the first
joint is inner joint
the inner joint returns only those
records that have matching values from
both the tables that is the left table
and right table next we have the outer
or full outer join now
outer join basically retrieves the data
from both the tables irrespective of
whether they are matching or not so it
will display the values either from left
table or from right table
now next we have the left join as the
name suggests the left John gives
priority to the first table or the left
table or the first table so it will
retrieve only the records that are
present in the left table and only the
matching records that are present from
the right table
and finally we have the right join right
join basically retrieves the data from
the right table or the second table and
only the matching values from the left
table or the first table so these are
some different types of joints we use in
SQL if you want to learn more about SQL
joints make sure to check out rsql joins
tutorial on our Channel where we have
discussed the syntax and its use cases
which with a certain examples and its
execution in MySQL workbench as well so
I would highly recommend you to check
that out
all right moving ahead next question is
what is explain the difference between a
join and a union in SQL
so now joints and unions can be used to
combine data from one or more tables now
the difference lies in how the data is
combined so in simple terms joins
combine data into new columns if two
tables are joined together then the data
from the first table is shown in one set
of column alongside the second tables
column in the same row so if you look at
this example where you have taken two
tables in a resultant tables The Columns
are being added side by side
so each row in the result contains
columns from both table A and B rows are
created when columns from one table
match columns from another so this match
is basically called the join condition
but when I speak about Union Union
combines data into new rows in a union
each row within the result is from one
table or the other in a union columns
aren't combined to create results but
rows are combined unions are typically
used when you have two results whose
rows you want to include in the same you
know same result that is if you want to
include the difference the rows in your
resultant set then in that case you have
to choose the union so that that was
some of the main differences between the
join and Union statement
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
is the difference between delete and
truncate delete command is used to
delete only specified number of rows
that is if you want to delete only
specific rows like one or more rows you
can uh use the delete statement whereas
the truncate command is used to delete
all the rows uh in a single go from a
table delete comes in a DML command that
is data manipulation language whereas
truncate is a ddl command which is data
definition language
now there may be a where clause in the
delete command in order to filter the
records since we are specifying uh
deleting only specifying specified rows
we can use a where Clause to limit the
number of rows that we want to delete
whereas we do not have the option to use
where clause in the truncate command as
it deletes all the rows simultaneously
Now using when you use a delete the
changes can be rolled back so once you
delete certain records from the table
you can use the rollback statement uh to
make changes again whereas if you use
the truncate the changes cannot be
rolled back once you are once you have
deleted the records from the table it
will completely uh just vanish from the
table and you do not have the you know
luxury to get back to its original state
that is it cannot be rolled back now
delete on a performance side the latest
slower than truncate because we are
individually deleting the rows whereas
truncate is faster than delete because
we are deleting all the rows at a single
time
so these are some of the main
differences between delete and truncate
and one thing you have to keep in mind
in that uh when you're using truncate
you have to be careful because once you
have once if you use the truncate and
once the deletion is done you cannot uh
get back to its original state that is
that changes can be rolled back so it is
very important that you choose these two
statements you know wisely
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
are subqueries and how they're used in
SQL now software is in SQL are another
important concept if you are trying to
solve complex SQL queries so in such
case sub queries can be quite handful so
you need to know what sub queries are
now as the statement says as an SQL sub
query is nothing but a query inside or
another queries and we use a sub query
to fetch data from more than one table
that is if you're retrieving data from
one or more tables we need some queries
and a sub queries also often referred to
as an inner query while the statement
containing a sub query is also called an
outer query or outer select statement we
can Implement some queries with the
select insert update and delete
statements along with the operators like
equals to greater than equals to in
between and Etc now consider an example
here where I'm trying to find you know
the Lister price of all the items
present in the orders table whose price
is greater than the average of total
listed price in that order table so here
the inner query becomes the select
average listed price from the order
table statement so it basically
calculates the result of this inner
query first and it passes on to the
outer query so let's say if I have the
average of the listed price is 100 so
the outer query basically selects the
name the listed price from the order
stable whose listed price is greater
than 100 so it will retrieve all the
data whose price in order table is
greater than 100 so in this way you can
use sub queries you know to find complex
or more you know to find inferences of
the complex queries by using a simple
sub query so I hope you understood what
sub queries are
let us now move ahead and discuss the
next question which is what is asset
property in a database now to ensure
that the database is in a consistent
State both before and after the
transaction one needs to follow certain
properties and those properties are
known as asset properties now where a
stands for atomicity C stands for
consistency I stands for isolation and b
stands for durability now talking about
atomicity the concept of automatic
atomicity describes how the data stays
Atomic so in other words if an action or
transaction is performed on the data it
should either be executed completed or
not executed at all
so changes in the data must be like a
single operation now next we have the
consistency consistency the idea behind
consistency is the value must constantly
be maintained now the Integrity of the
data should be upheld in dbms or SQL
which means the changes uh done to the
database should always always be saved
next we have isolation now the
characteristic guarantees that uh
numerous transactions can take
simultaneously without causing the
database state to become inconsistent so
transaction uh takes place without
interruption and independently so
changes made in one transaction are not
visible to changes made in any other
transaction until the change in question
has been committed or not so isolation
basically checks whether the transaction
is getting successful in case of any
system failures or not and finally we
have durability now durability as the
name suggests something which a
transaction done is permanent if it is
durable durability in dbms or SQL refers
to the guarantee that data remains in
the database permanently once an
operation has been successfully
completed so these are the asset
properties that are present in a
database which are also quite useful
when you are working on SQL database
because it should satisfy the condition
uh in the tables that you are working on
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question what are
common table expression in SQL now a CT
or Common Table expression defines a
temporary result set that a user can
refer possibly multiple times uh within
a SQL statement so if you're serving
someone working on large databases and
if you want to use the queries that have
already created you can just simply make
us comment table expression where in it
enables user to write and maintain the
queries easily with increased
readability and reusability
now CTS are more readable than sub query
which makes it and go to SQL statement
or the concept now CT basically
increases the performance of the query
now instead of writing the query each
and every time while you're working on a
database you can just simply already
call The Common Table expression that
you have created earlier now the syntax
of CT is written as with CTE name that
is you have to mention the CT name as
within the parenthesis select column one
column two from tables and close the
parenthesis and again mention the select
statement column one column two from CT
name that you have written and you can
also mention the condition using the
where Plus
so that was about all about the Common
Table expressions in SQL
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss what is normalization in SQL
again guys normalization is a quite
important concept even if you are
working on a dbms or SQL Concepts I
think it is important to prepare uh well
uh for your interviews and this is one
of the important question if you are
preparing for that now a normalization
is basically the process to eliminate
data redundancy and enhance data
Integrity in the table so it basically
uh is useful to you know uh have the
data redundancy and inconsistency at
place it is basically a multi-step
process that step that sets the data in
a tabular form and removes the
duplicated data from the relational
tables so and also we have different
types of normal forms guys so you need
to prepare all of them and interviewer
interviewer might ask you one of the
normal forms that is uh present so we
have four different types of normal
forms such as one NF two and F3 NF and P
CNF now a following question can be uh
you know to explain any of the normal
form now I'm considering here what is
first normal form so
for a table to be in first normal form
and now the atomicity of the table is
one that is every table should contain a
single value and each and every record
must be unique now let us understand
with an example here let's say I have a
table of students which has roll number
name age courses as different fields now
as you can see for one student we have
multiple courses present in the same
record so we have for Hersh he has opted
for courses SQL and Java now as per the
first normalization definition it is not
correct because it shouldn't have
multiple values present in one record or
one column so we can this we can
eliminate this by you know converting
into a separate row that is we might
have uh you know repeated values but it
should be unique values so I have
written SQL and Java into separate table
into separate columns in a resultant
table which basically satisfies the
first normal form
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question what is the
difference between SQL and MySQL now the
interviewer white might want to
understand your you know in-depth
knowledge whether you are understanding
you know the differences between a MySQL
which is a relational database and an
SQL which is a programming language so
the difference is basically SQL is a
programming language whereas MySQL is a
relational database management system
which is used to you know perform
various uh operations like insert update
delete on the data that is stored in the
database
so SQL is a language which is useful in
querying relational database system and
again whereas MySQL is used to store
modify and delete data in a database in
an organized way SQL is a licensed
product of Microsoft whereas MySQL is an
open source platform managed by Oracle
Corporation
SQL provides adequate protection to SQL
servers against Intruders whereas MySQL
being an open source platform we cannot
guarantee the security as it is
unreliable
coming to SQL it doesn't support any
connectors whereas in MySQL we have
various tools such as MySQL workbench in
order to build databases so these are
some of the major differences between
the SQL and MySQL
the next question is write an SQL query
to find second highest salary from
employee table now we all know to find
the highest salary we can simply use the
max you know aggregate function so the
following query would be select ID
employee name maximum of salary from
employee all right but what if you want
to find second highest salary that is
where a sub query comes into picture you
need to use a sub query to First find
select maximum salary from the table and
then you have to retrieve your
particular columns that is employee Name
ID or maximum salary from employee where
salary is less than that maximum salary
so something which is less than the max
would be the second highest right so
that is what the logic is and we are
doing that simply with use of sub
queries here
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is
explain the differences between where
and having Clause so where Clause is
used to filter the records from the
table based on specific condition
whereas having Clause is also used to
filter record from the groups based on a
specific condition where Clause can be
used without Group by clause and having
Clause cannot be used without Guru by
Clause where Clause implements in a row
operation whereas having Clause
implements in column operations now in
general where Clause cannot contain
aggregate function whereas in having
Clause you can include various aggregate
functions like count some average
minimum maximum Etc and finally where
Clause can be used with select update
drift statement while you cannot use any
of this statement with having plus where
you can just only use the select
statement
so that was the differences between
where and having clause
the next question is write an SQL query
to return even and odd number records
from table now I hope you guys know the
logic behind this it is a simple SQL
query you just have to use the model as
operator which Returns the records with
order even values for that we need to
check the reminder when we divide the
column value by 2. so when the reminder
is 0 that is basically an even number
otherwise it's an odd number so the
query for even number records is Select
start from table where ID modulus 2 is
equals to 0 and for odd number odd
number records you need to write a query
as select star from table where ID
modulus 2 not equals to 0.
all right the next question is what is
the difference between a function and
procedure functions and stored procedure
another important concept but their way
of implementation is bit of similar so
but you need to understand the
differences on how they work so function
basically returns a value that is it
should always return a value when you
are writing when you're performing a a
complex function on your data database
table and function can be called from a
select query as well and function is
generally used to perform some
calculation and always return a result
whereas on the other hand start
procedures cannot be used in SQL
statements anywhere in the where having
or Select Plus
procedures can either return a single
multiple or no values at all that is we
have an optional condition here that
procedure may or may not return values
in the resultant set
Now using short procedure we can prepare
SQL code which you can see so that the
code can be reused again and again which
is not with the case of function so
stored procedure can be quite helpful
again if you are working a large data
set and if you want to retrieve uh
values and if you want to fetch data in
that case stored procedure can be quite
useful as you cannot uh you know as you
can use it
simultaneously or multiple times
okay
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is how
to create a new table from an existing
table now creating a new table from on
already uh you know created table is a
bit of easy you just have to use uh we
create and select statement so as it
states a copy of a table can be created
from an existing table using the
combination of both create and select
statement and the syntax is create table
mention the new table name as mention
the select statement inside the columns
that you want to retrieve from the
already present table that is from the
existing table and you can also mention
the where now if you want only a
particular column in that case you can
use the where condition so that was how
that is how you can create a new table
from an existing table again this is a
simple you know SQL query wherein the
interviewer wants to know if you are you
know having proper knowledge on the
tables like of creating a tables foreign
the next question is how is SQL
different from nosql now you guys might
might have heard about nosql which is
basically trending a lot nowadays where
it is used to store a lot of
unstructured data now as the data is
increasing day by day SQL has been in a
downside where it is unable to store you
know a lot of unstructured data that is
coming from the internet and from the
you know World Wide Web so in that case
you know companies have switched to
another technology which uses a new you
know way of storing the data be it you
know unstructured or semi-structured
data which is nosql however there are
differences between SQL and nosql that
is SQL is a relational database that is
it comprises of rows and columns in a
table and it is only stored in that
format while no SQL is a non-relational
database which basically you know stores
data in a key value pair or a document
based or a graph based these are
structured and while SQL has a fixed
schema design and structure that is you
need to you know give the table
structure that is you need to predefine
the schema that is your rows or your
columns in hindsight whereas noise scale
has a dynamic schema design and
structure that is you need not provide
you know a schema if you're working on
noise scale database SQL handles complex
queries whereas nosql handles large
volumes of data so let's say if you have
some data present in your table and if
you are you know constantly working on
it and Performing complex queries in
that case you need SQL to retrieve the
data whereas if you are having large
volumes of data in that case you can use
nosql SQL is vertically scalable while
nosql is horizontally scalable
now from what do I mean scalable is
basically as a term used in database
whereas scalability is the ability to
expand or contract the capacity of
system resources in order to support the
Ever Changing usage of your applications
now when I talk about vertical scaling
it refers to increasing the processing
power of a single server or cluster now
both relational as well as the
non-relational database can scale up but
eventually there will be a limit in
terms of Maximum processing power and
throughput whereas the horizontal
scaling also known as the scale out
method refers to Bringing on additional
nodes to start the ring that is you can
even improve you can even add CPUs and
ramps to your existing server now this
is difficult with relational databases
because due to difficulty in spreading
out related data across the nodes but
with non-relational database or with SQL
this is made simpler since collections
which we use in nosql are self-contained
under coupled relationally and finally
SQL follows asset property that we have
already discussed in our previous
question which is what is asset property
and whereas NOS skill follows cap
property so these were some of the main
difference between you know the
traditional SQL language and the new or
the emerging technology that is no SQL
all right moving ahead the next question
is write an SQL query to find the nth
highest salary from a table now if
you're a beginner or someone working as
an SQL Developer even to an intermediate
level uh finding you know first second
third highest salary can be quite easy
you know using you know sub queries or
functions but whereas to find the nthis
salary you need a bit of more of
assistance so using a sub query you can
find the inside a higher salary wherein
the query is written as select salary
from employees as employee one where n
minus 1. now here n basically denotes
the higher and highest salary that you
want to calculate let's say if I want to
find the 35th highest salary you need to
mention 35 in the end Place equals to
select count distance salary from
employees as employee to I'm giving an
alias name here where employee two dot
salary is greater than employee one dot
salary now
the logic behind this is I'm basically
self joining the same table again and
I'm comparing the two tables wherein it
will compare the salary from the second
table which is greater than the first
salary and it will retrieve the data in
the resultant set now you can use this
or do this in another way using the
limit Clause the query is written as
select star from employees where salary
is equals to select distinct salary from
employees order by salary limit n comma
1. now this is applicable in most of the
databases that you're working on like
MySQL SQL server or even Oracle as well
where you just have to specify the N
value and use a limit clause and it will
do the rest
so let's say if I want to find uh 50th
highest salary in place of n i can
basically put 50 also and we can also
find the nth highest salary using the
row number function now if you want to
know in detail on how to use the row
number function and the syntax of it you
can check out our video uh on how to
find highest salary from our from a
table in our Channel where we have
discussed clearly on how to use various
different methods and especially how to
use the row number function as well so
I'd highly recommend you guys to check
that out
all right moving ahead the next question
is name the operator which is used for
pattern matching in SQL now SQL like
command or operator is is used to find a
specific character in our database so it
basically determines whether a specific
character that you are mentioning
matches a pattern string or not now this
is used uh to perform complex pattern
search in data wherein you don't know
the uh you know complete you know
information that you are working on the
data so
just with the help of some certain
specifics or specific characters that
I'm talking here about uh you can
basically retrieve the data the syntax
is followed as select column one column
two column in from table name where
column name like pattern let us just
understand this an example where again
you can have a follow-up question for
this where it is where the individual
interviewer can ask you write an SQL
query to fetch the employees whose name
begins with any two characters followed
by a text R A which is basically two
characters and ends with any sequence of
characters now in general we have two
different like operators which is
underscore and percentage wildcard
characters where underscore matches a
single character and percentage matches
0 or multiple characters
so the answer to this query is basically
select employee name from employees
where employee name like within the
parenthesis now as I as the question is
stated as it should begin with any two
characters so I can basically put an
underscore here for the first two places
followed by a text which is array and it
can end with any number of characters so
let's say if I have murali whose name
starts with m and the next character is
U so you can take it as m u r a and it
can end with any characters again l i so
murali is an example for this or else
you can take Surat again you can have
two different characters in the first
position and it can end with any number
of characters at the end so this is how
you can use like operator in order to
fetch certain patterns when you are not
aware of the uh you know
string or the data that you are trying
to retrieve from the database table
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is
explain what is an alias in SQL and why
we use it now I'm sure you know what uh
the term Alias is it is giving a
temporary name to someone so similarly
in SQL also it is basically a temporary
name that is given to a table or a
column while writing a query now Alias
can be quite useful because let's say if
you're working on a database and if the
columns or the table names are so long
now you have to write or type the
database table again and again in such
long format so instead of that I can
simply write a Alias name for that now
let's say I have employee details as my
table name now instead of writing every
time employee details I can just give
another Alias name like EMP or EMP
details so giving aliasis makes the
table or column name more readable as
well now if you are using Alias it is a
temporary change guys so it is limited
to the runtime of the query wherein you
are executing a query so it will just
give a layer's name for only that moment
and it is not permanently saved so if
you're performing for column operations
the Alias can be used as select column
name as Alias name from table and if you
are giving an arya's name for table you
can write a select column one or column
so on up to n columns from table name as
Alias name
all right let us now discuss the next
question which is explain views in SQL
now a database view in SQL is like
having virtual tables containing a
single query and its result now the
result is usually a virtual table which
is having the same amount of rows and
columns just like the actual table so we
can either pass a query to store all the
rows and Columns of a table or just a
part of it now the most significant
advantage of using a view in SQL is that
it oh it also stores the query and hence
we don't write we don't have to write it
again and again from this scratch but
again then the question arises why not
use a stored procedure instead now even
the stored procedures can hold a query
and execute whenever called however the
advantage with views is that they are
easier and more straightforward compared
to procedure and the query is queries
written as create view view name as
select column one column two up to so on
column n from you can write a single
table or from multiple tables as well
you can you all also use a wire
condition
so we can just uh easily create a view
in SQL from a single table or even
multiple tables using the create view
statement but before anything else we
need to create uh we need to already
have a table so that we can create a
view for it so that was views in SQL and
how they are used
all right the next question is what are
triggers in SQL
so a trigger is basically a stored
procedure which is a set of SQL
statements saved under a name just like
a function or even when you're writing
you know views which takes a temporary
name so that it can be reused that is uh
triggers can be executed that are
automatically uh you know called on when
there is any change in the database now
for instance you may program a trigger
to execute when data is inserted in a
table now we have different types of
triggers as well based on the event and
the timing of it so we have a different
DML triggers we have ddl triggers and
database triggers so now in DML we have
insert update and delete and in ddl
triggers we can use create and Order
statements now the timing is also
important when you are triggering a data
triggering certain event that is you can
use before trigger that is you can use
before insert trigger that is whenever
you're trying to insert a new record if
it is not satisfying the condition that
you have specified then it will omit so
it basically backfires before this
specified event has occurred similarly
you can use after trigger as well which
basically you know fires after a
specified event has already occurred
so that was triggers in SQL
so an immediate following uh question
would be why we use SQL triggers being
an advanced level concept the
interviewer might want to know the
in-depth knowledge of what SQL triggers
are so SQL triggers allows the user to
avoid redundant code with multiple
programs need to perform the same
database operations it also maintains
complex column constraints and refresh
inferential or data integrity and also
it prevents invalid transactions and
make sure that the user that is
authenticating a transaction is being
successfully executed
and finally it increases the performance
of the SQL queries because it does not
need to compile each and every time when
the query is getting executed so there's
those are some of the main reasons why
we use SQL triggers
all right moving on let us now discuss
the next question which is what is
indexing in SQL now indexing in X SQL is
a special table used to speed up the
searching process of the data in a
database table now let's say if you're
working on thousands and thousands of
record it becomes quite difficult you
know if you try to retrieve certain data
which are ultimately impacts the
performance of the query now let's say
let's take an example here now you all
might have you know done this in your
school days wherein you have this
textbooks and in textbooks you have
table of contents now if you want to
refer to a particular chapter instead of
searching from page one and
simultaneously moving on to the next
Pages you can just check the index page
where you can find the number now let's
say in the example I want to find the uh
concepts of the neural science of
hospitality which has an index 62. so
instead of searching from the start I
can just turn on to the 60 second page
and just refer to the contents that are
present in that chapter so similarly in
SQL as well instead of searching
you know the whole table you can just
speed up the process by using an index
so the main benefit of using indexing is
it improves query speed as discussed and
faster data recovery is also another
Factor when using indexing and also it
the efficiency that is the search
efficiency of the query increases
wherein the performance of the database
ultimately impacts on how you are
running the query now the more the com
the more complex the queries the more
you know performance it takes which
ultimately impacts the efficiency so if
you're trying to perform you know data
operations on more than you know 1000
records or let's say one lakh records in
a table in that case you can use index
the final question guys uh which is what
are the applications of SQL in real life
nowadays SQL has been uh in a tremendous
you know usage for more than many
sectors in in real life as well for
example if you take banking banking
sector is an important you know criteria
for our nation for its development so
banking uses SQL and it is one of the
major components in banking sector where
Bank stores the account details of
customers and the transaction
transactions done in the database on a
regular basis it is also used in
education sectors like schools and
universities where
the you know users or the people in uh
authorization use SQL and databases to
store and retrieve information about
their students faculty and staff
information
next we have Finance Finance in a is
another massive area where SQL queries
are used regularly in managing the
assets Revenue details shares of the
companies now faster execution and
retrieval of data plays an important
role for all the businesses around the
world to make strategies and derive
insights from it and for that we need
SQL to retrieve the data as early as
possible
and next we have Healthcare again
hospitals and other medical centers use
SQL to store the details of the patients
without any hassle it also helps in
maintaining all the documents necessary
builds as well Etc
manufacturing is another important you
know sector where SQL is used and
considering the vast presence in the
market manufacturing also uses SQL in
order to
find that data from the Machinery the
employees that are working in a
particular manufacturing plant and Etc
it is also widely used in travel also in
order to store the details of the
customers let's say if they have any uh
you know offers to be presented in real
time we use SQL in order to store all of
this in no time
and finally we have e-commerce as well
now companies like Amazon Flipkart uh
you know considering its best presence
in the market retail and e-commerce
company stores its customer data to
improve their shopping experience by
providing special offers which in turn
helps the business to grow so these are
some of the uh applications in of SQL in
real life I hope you guys have
understood
so here we wrap up with SQL full course
if you have any queries feel free to add
it in the comment section and our
experts will be happy to help you if you
like this video do subscribe to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us thanks for
watching this video
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign